Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello.
Oh gosh, okay.
So, welcome, welcome class.
Welcome class to VTubing 101 by Professor Doki.
I just need to let you guys know that I need, before I
start, um, a big disclaimer for all of you, but this is all
my own opinion so like obviously to each person it is
different how this is done i am a very unique circumstance
in terms of like what the fuck happened to me so
so i just need you guys to know this is like all my own
opinion in terms of like content creation and like vtubing
and stuff like that like all the tips and advice is from
what I feel is how to build an audience and how to nurture a
fan community.
I realized I just remembered I forgot that slide.
I forgot to make that slide regarding like how to nurture a
fan community.
I forgot to make it.
So I'll talk to you guys about that later.
I was like, I knew I forgot something.
I knew I forgot one thing to talk about regarding like a V2.
One of the most a fan community like a community um a
community that is like you know um how to nurture it and how
to like grow it in a way and making sure they like you know
they'll continue to watch you so so stuff like that i
realized i knew i forgot to make one important slide and um
that was one of them so um so i will talk about it i will
sadly there won't be a slide about it so i guess like if
you're looking back you're just gonna have to remember where
i talked about it and stuff like that so like i said this is
all my own opinion um in regards to like all of this um it
will touch on about like content creation as well not just
like vtubing in general because like although vtubing is a
niche type deal it's like its own niche within the streaming
community um a lot of these like things i talk about can
also apply to general streaming like it doesn't have to you
don't have to be a vtuber you could just be like a flesh
tuber or like just a png tuber or whatever it all like it's
just just general advice on like algorithm and stuff like
that a lot of this is like very like um it's like very
what's the word it's very uh uh it might be like very simple
advice and it could be like things like oh i knew that
already or stuff like that but some people might not you
know some people might not know this this already this info
and stuff like that or like they might not be aware that
like oh wait that's the thing and stuff like that so there's
going to be some advice that to others might seem very
simple but might help it might help others and then there
might be some advice that you might not know also um so i'll
try to touch as much as i can there will be like i will take
questions uh but of course i will pick and choose what
questions I would like to answer um at the end and from chat
and then I will take some questions I will also be looking
reading through the Twitter thread that I've made regarding
like people on Twitter that have asked me like questions
regarding um regarding like uh like what they want to know
more about like what my process is and stuff like that so I
will be looking at Twitter as well as chat later on to
answer some of the questions people have because like
there's somewhere people were asking me how do you do a
project how do you start a project What do you do?
Well, like, this is like, I didn't make a slide for stuff
like this because like when doing projects, it's not really
that complicated of a process in general unless you get
sponsors involved.
Like the moment you get sponsors involved or like you have
something else that's funding it for you, it doesn't, it's
not that complicated.
It's as complicated as you want to make it to be.
So I didn't make a slide about that because I felt like it
really is like your own work process regarding projects.
stuff like that.
So like, of course, if you have a sponsor involved, if you
have someone else involved, obviously what they want to do
with your project matters a lot, because they have a say,
since they're funding it, they have a say on how this
project is going to go.
So or you can fund it yourself, which is basically if you
fund it yourself, you get 100% on where your creativity is
going towards.
It's like how a lot of like passion projects are usually
funded by themselves, because they don't want like a higher
upper person to like dictate what it's going to be like.
And only you just want to do what you want to do.
So it's basically like if you want funding, yeah, you don't
have to pay for yourself.
But a lot of the creative control is out of your hands.
So like it's like very restricted, but if you funded
yourself, obviously you have the majority of creative
control on how things are going.
So that's why I didn't make a slide because it's like it
really heavily depends.
on like how you want to do your project so um i can give you
how to organize your product like in terms of like how i
organize my projects regarding what the discord servers will
look like i can give you guys an insight on like how i
separate a discord server and stuff like that so there will
be like pictures and everything don't worry this stream will
be uh it's it's archived this so do not worry this stream is
archived so you guys can rewatch it whenever you want
regarding stuff like this um and i said before i will not be
going over anything that will break any aims or um anything
that is like very private information i will not be going
through any of that um i will mostly be going through like
um i guess general knowledge that's already been out like
companies versus indies.
Should you join a company or should you be an indie?
I'll be talking about like pros and cons.
But all this information is a general knowledge.
It is out in public.
So like, and it's not like NDA, it doesn't break any NDAs.
A lot of this information is out in public, but it's more so
I give like a highlighter on like separating what are the
benefits between why people want to join a company and why
people want to join, want to continue being an indie.
There are pros and cons for each.
and indie you'll see why people will go for either um and um
there are bit uh there are benefits for each one so the
first off i'm going to also i realized there's no bgm but i
just i was trying to find a good bgm but i don't know i
don't know what to use as a bgm like i mean i do have this a
classic i could do that you know what i'll have this be my
bgm all right this is gonna be my bgm anyway so um uh we
were gonna go with the first slide uh we're gonna go with a
classic so um the first slide the biggest factor before i go
into any of this the biggest factor regarding how to make it
as a content creator and like as a vtuber is luck and
networking and like i'm not going to deny that luck pays a
huge factor if you watch any like video i've got regarding
like how do i become a content creator how do i be a big
famous streamer how do i become famous everybody will tell
you that luck is one of the biggest when it comes to
streaming to make it as a streamer it's your biggest your
big break basically um but even when you have your big break
you must be able to utilize it to keep the momentum so like
you can't you can't just like have something you got your
biggest break ever but then you don't utilize anything
regarding it you just coast after that that kills all your
momentum like I think that's like really like that is like
very for some people that is incredibly obvious but there's
so many times when someone will have their big break and
then they do nothing with it they just coast they'll just
keep on streaming as if it's normal the thing is when you
get your biggest break ever you have to like keep up the
momentum and a lot of eyes are on you at that point you
gotta grind you can't just take a break right after you get
your like biggest opportunity because sometimes when they
get their big break they'll be like i'm not gonna stream
after uh i'm not gonna stream after like two to three days
that your momentum's gone you gotta milk it
It's like it seems so like simple, but it's something that a
lot of people don't realize you can't you know You're like
oh, you have to take a break.
You have to rest But when you have the biggest opportunity
of your life You can't rest until you're stable But the the
huge thing is that streaming isn't stable Content creation
isn't stable but you have but when you have this opportunity
you have to keep going until you feel like you're safe that
you won't lose this anymore like and like that is why I'm
like I was a huge workaholic when I started out and I still
am because I do really enjoy streaming um as when you feel
like you're at a safe position that's when you can relax Um,
because when you lose this, the luck to your opportunity,
when will you get it again type deal?
You have to go in thinking that you only have one huge
opportunity.
And you have to go in with milking that huge opportunity for
as long as you can until you realize you're in a safe and
stable position to relax.
but a huge huge uh like negative side to this is that some
streamers don't know when they are in a safe position that
is like the hardest part and that's why a lot of streamers
and a lot of content creators don't know when to take a
break because they don't know when they are stable and
that's why you see a lot of burnout and a lot of like
streamers burning out or like just not being able to keep
going because they don't know exactly when this when the
right moment is to relax and that is a huge problem because
streaming is also very new it's not a very long career we
don't know the effects of streaming as a long career right
now we are seeing youtubers finally like quitting after like
what 20 plus years on youtube um we're now seeing like big
youtubers finally deciding to retire but those are youtubers
we have yet to see the outcome of streamers at best a lot of
the big streamers a lot of the famous streamers are still
going so like we're seeing big youtubers finally retiring
but we haven't seen big streamers finally taking a break or
fine not taking a break but finally retiring so at this
point we don't know what's happened we don't know the career
of streaming in general uh
germa kind of retired but germa is still sort of he's still
like sort of going ongoing type deal he's not really like
retired retired he's like semi retired but even then we're
not he's like one of the biggest out there like he is
literally okay you can say like making it and streaming is
one percent germa is like the zero point zero zero one
percent because he has become a meme so because of that he
has like transcended to like meme status forever type deal
it's it's forever type deal um and because of that like he
it's a different story regarding like regular shimmers um
and so there's there's lots of things like this to worry
about like you have to know when you can relax and when you
can take a break and i feel like when you have your biggest
opportunities you i personally think like you keep going
until like you can to see that, uh, that your growth has
stabilized type deal.
Like, it has stabilized to a number that you think is going
to be your average for a while, and that even you take a
break, like maybe like one to two weeks break.
I know like some people are like a month break or something.
I personally think, this is my opinion, but I personally
think one to two weeks is like the optimal length you can
take as a, for a break in V2.
and content creation.
Well, content creation is another hand, but I think in
V-tubing, one to two weeks is the optimal spot.
If you're in a company, you might be able to take a longer
break.
But if you're an indie, one to two weeks is the optimal spot
for a break, because you're not going long enough that it
will affect your algorithm, and you're not going long enough
that, like, uh that like people have you know watched other
streamers and stuff like that um one in two weeks is like
the safe zone anything more than that it's a little bit of
like a gamble it's like how it's more so of like how much
have you like nurtured your fan base to be able to uh to be
able to like take longer breaks um this is as i said this is
all my own opinion um if you're on twitch you don't
algorithm that much uh but like if you're on youtube
algorithm is like very very important um because it affects
on how much your content is being pushed outside of the
regular sphere uh so it really uh why is it not to work be
worried on twitch is because there's no the you the twitch
algorithm is different from the youtube algorithm the twitch
algorithm is mostly just We've got the like, oh, streamers
you want to watch, you might recommend and stuff like that.
But Twitch growth is mostly relied on raids, which I will
talk about in another slide.
Raids and VTuber collabs or collaborations in general really
help benefits Twitch growth.
While on YouTube, YouTube growth really benefits on the
algorithm and what you upload and what you're streaming and
types like that.
hard carry twitch twitch content creators because you're
like funneling viewers into like other other people it's
very easy to funnel viewers to other people youtube is more
so of regarding uploads like shorts videos and like um how
much you're growing and your consistency the moment you're
you're coasting on youtube the less youtube will push you
out to other new viewers and i have algorithm and uh matrix
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i love
gambling ah so you're you're a super chat reader gambler
will dokey read my slide
anyway another thing i want to talk about is networking um
your growth heavily relies on networking and who you reach
out to and who you're working with who you're socializing
with um Like, it relies heavily on your social skills and
how open you are to reaching out to people type deal.
It doesn't have to be, like, friendships and stuff.
It could be just like a, like, it doesn't have to be
friendship.
Like, you don't have to be friends with everybody.
It can be just like a casual, like, relationship between,
like, business partners and stuff like that.
It doesn't have to be, it can just be like a coworker or
something, and it doesn't have to be a friendship.
It can be a colleague, yeah, it could be a colleague, and,
like, just someone, like, mutual, mutual, like, collab
partners.
So it doesn't, you don't have to force yourself to be
friends with everybody, especially if you're, like, an
introvert like me.
I don't have to force myself to be friends with like
everybody I meet um type deal uh I don't I meet people but I
don't have to be like force friendships on people because it
has to be mutual it has to be a mutual friendship and like
there's like mutual um like you can you feel like you groove
with somebody also like some their stream personalities is
not the same as how I portray myself on stream I'm like
super energetic I'm like I'm like chaotic and stuff like
that um but I'm also an introvert so like uh on stream it's
very easy for me to be like that because like I very much
enjoy streaming and um and I very much enjoy streaming and I
very like I love like making content and stuff like that but
like off stream I am very like Chill.
I'm, I'm like, super, I'm, like, chill, and I'm, like, low
energy, because I put all my energy into, on, onto stream
type deal.
Like, I put a lot of my energies on stream, and, like, you
know, my battery is low off stream.
So, my off stream is, like, very different, because I, most
of my energy, and most of my battery is on stream.
um so like i said like on stream maybe you like grew with
somebody's on stream personality like the on stream
chemistry is uh is like really really good but me off stream
you're just casual acquaintances and stuff like that so like
i said you don't have to be friends with everybody but it's
really good to like know people at least like you know know
some people for example like twitch rivals um when i got
invited to when i first got invited twitch rivals i talked
with um i talked with like the head one of the head people
who organizes twitch rivals um i had talked with them i like
uh gave them like ideas and my opinions on stuff and i told
them like oh i really enjoyed twitch rivals it was really
really fun um if you um if possible um can i uh is it
possibly invited in future twitch rivals because i really
enjoyed doing them and i was acting i could have just like
done twitch rivals and not cared about it after that but
instead i personally reached out to the head of the twitch
rivals organizer and told them how much i enjoy doing them
how much like um how much uh my my fans enjoying me doing
them and how i would love to participate more in the future
and that is how i got my connections with twitch uh is
because i took the extra step to interact with the pet
people who are organizing these events and uh and then just
be like i really enjoyed it and like um if possible can i be
invited to uh to future twitch rivals and that's really it
that's how i basically got like invites consistently to like
these events uh and just you have fun on them i do it shows
in my streams and it shows when i reached out directly to
the p organizers and like uh and that's also like it doesn't
matter it is not this applies to every like everything like
events and like events and all this other stuff if you ask
directly uh the worst you can say is no like or ghost you
and you already you took your shot
Like, you took your shot, and that's all that matters.
And it's all about, like, taking your shot.
You have to get onto these opportunities and be able to
interact with people and, like, openly ask about, like,
whether or not it's possible to do these things.
Like, and, I mean, if they ghost you, then you're, like,
fine, you move on.
You have to be able to accept rejection and getting ghosted
because that is the way of being a streamer and content
creator it's gonna fucking hurt but like I got ghosted uh
and rejected for things like and I'm okay I'm not fine but
but you have to accept it like that's the thing you need to
accept rejection also friend thank you for the akasupa thank
you thank you sorry professor almost forgot to pay for class
oh yeah oh yeah sorry for your girls you don't know the
tuition the class tuition anyway like i said that is one of
the biggest factors on like making it as a content creator
um but yes like i said luck is why a lot of people want to
join a company because it already making it into a company
is the luck part and it already comes with an established
and after that even when you make it to the company it's
your job to keep those eyes on you and continue building it
because it's not like you can coast after that it's like you
have to keep going after that or you're just gonna stagnate
so which is why my next slide will be going over indie
versus company so I'll be going over company first and a lot
of this is uh sort of like public knowledge so like i'm not
i'm not like going to be going to any details regarding like
anything that could break nta and stuff like that but a lot
of this information is like public knowledge that i'm pretty
sure um like it doesn't matter if it's like a small company
or a big company it generally is like it's very like to the
point regarding like situations and stuff like this so uh so
like So obviously I'll be going over like why should you
join a company and About how and also like things to be
aware of and like I said you get an instant audience
audience base So the audience of the company and of the
vTubers That debut before you will be there for your debut
Obviously because a lot of you might not be the first person
there You know you might you might it might not if it's not
a new company that you're starting uh there is already the
branding involved so you're going in with uh you're going in
with like an established audience uh and because of that
that's why a lot of people want to join um if you're nobody
if you came with zero viewers then of course like having
suddenly on your debut like i don't know 20 plus viewers if
you come from zero 20 plus 100 200 a thousand that's a lot
from what you were used to um it draws a lot of attention
and it's your job to make a good debut so you can keep the
attention of those people uh that watched you they don't
know anything about you but they're all here to be there to
watch you they know zero things zero things your skin suit
is and like what your personality is like on twitter and
that's it that's all the information they have of you but
even so you're going in there with an established audience
base that are fans of the company or the vtubers that came
before you and um and they're here to watch you so you have
all this exposure right off the bat you could be a hidden
gem out there as an indie for a company and it's up to the
company to reveal why you're a hidden gem and uh because
there's so many really good indies out there that never had
their big break but it's only because of joining a company
they receive their big break and that is why a lot of people
take that chance another reason why is because you get a
group of people to collaborate with instantly and And this
is one of the things that I've learned as an indie, how it's
very difficult as an indie is to find a group of people or a
collab group that you want to do collabs with and be able to
like, you know, organize something really easily in general.
So at a company, you can literally just ask anybody.
Like there might be a server or something and you just be
like, at everyone, I want to play this game.
I want to play this game and I need people to play there.
I need three people.
And that is why one reason, one of the reasons why people
want to join.
They want a sense of community and they want to send a group
of people to be able to play games with or like to be able
to organize stuff with.
And it's why a lot of people would want to join.
And that makes sense.
You don't, as anything, you have to socialize and meet
people and get close enough to invite.
them to things um and when you're in a company you don't
really have to do that you don't it could be colleagues or
something and you can just be like hey you guys want to do
this i don't really know you but like you're in the company
um so like obviously let's do something together
so so it gives like a security of like having a group of
people that you can just work with and And you don't have to
contact people outside your circle to fill in spots or work
on socializing And the number reason is if you're a singer
or a dancer So the reason why I put that is that it's very
beneficial for If you have talents in singing or dancing to
work for a company And because of that because the reasoning
is that a lot of the biggest events that VTuber companies do
It doesn't matter how big or small are concerts and and like
singing and if you're talented at singing you will get
picked to do concerts if you can sing you'll get those
opportunities to perform around the world for fans since
you're under a group you can do big group concerts with lots
of other singers and it's much easier to set up versus as an
individual and all the costs are within from the company and
that's why if you're a singer or a dancer it really benefits
you because like like i said um you get to pick be picked to
do these types of events and um and these are like one of
these not the i won't say the easiest events to organize but
like the most common events to uh to see uh being hosted by
vtuber companies because it's like one some things that fans
love and some things that is easy not easy but like um they
have a lot of experience organizing um and also like they
have access to like uh music labels maybe um it depends on
which company you're joining but um um if you want to be
want to make it more if you want to be like more well known
as a singer it's easier to do that when you're joining a
company versus being an individual um because getting your
talents out there is easier because of that.
As well as like, not only that, but cover songs, group
songs, karaoke's, these are like some of the easiest ways to
help boost not only your channel, but the company's branding
as well.
So like these are like some of the things to be aware of.
Because like I said, hosting concerts and stuff like that
worldwide is like some of the easiest things to do as an
entertainer.
For me, I think it's one of the reasons why I felt like I
was I'd be slacking off or like not worth much Because as a
person who can't sing or a beginner You have to think what
can I offer to the company that can be used for events and
big productions And it's harder because you have to be more
creative and know where your own talents lie For me, I would
say like gaming But I can't really do that I can't have like
host like a big event Regarding like fan event regarding
gaming like it has very like harder I feel like personally
it might be harder to do versus like singing so like Also,
like if you know whatever like oh, but Doki what about like
tournaments and stuff like that?
It's harder because you can't do like LAN stuff if you're a
V-tuber
Like, you know, like, I mean, there's, like, moment, like,
because, like, you can't go to land.
So, like, that's different.
You can't be like, oh, my God.
Because, like, I've had moments where I was invited to do,
like, I have moments in the past where I was invited to do
things like, like, like, physical meet and greets for, like,
gaming stuff, or, like, I had to be there like I I won't
show up I won't like be there on the stage but I had to be
there like at the event and I had to say no because as a
vtuber that is very dangerous
I I said no for these because like um uh like obviously like
risk-wise like being there physically being there um is for
as a vtuber there's a lot of risks to it so i've i've had to
say no to like LAN events in the past where I had to
actually be there to play the game and I didn't feel very
comfortable with that I didn't feel very comfortable uh
because I was worried that was like I was worried because I
was like I don't know if I'll be actually if like I'll be
safe type deal.
So in the past, I have said no to these opportunities.
Also, another thing is if the main branch is non-English
speaking, but you speak the language, one of the reasons why
I put this here is that if you want to apply for a company
whose main branch is in English speaking, I strongly suggest
learning that language while you're applying or if you make
it in.
offers so many opportunities, including being able to
collaborate with talents and participate in main branch
events.
If it is only in that language and signups are exclusive to
being able to speak that language, you're obviously shutting
down a huge set of network and a huge set of opportunities
that you wouldn't be able to access.
access if you don't learn that language.
It makes sense because you have to be able to communicate
with everyone and be able to keep the production going.
And another thing is that the main consumer base and
experience will also be in the main branch.
Most of the sales and consumer products might be exclusive
to one country because manufacturing and shipping is just
easier.
You know, it's all there.
Right, right, right, right.
So, like, it's all there.
Like, overseas shipping is very expensive.
So, maybe they want to make something that is exclusive to,
like, this particular country, because it's just easier,
especially if it's, like, brand deals or, like, sponsors.
It's, like, only located in one region.
So it's just easier in the long run.
It's hard to learn a new language.
But if you're trying to apply for a company, or if you're
trying to get into a company main language is in english it
might as well you might as well do it if you want to grow as
a content creator in that company um and if you're so it's
like it's super understandable why it would be very
beneficial to you uh to and like if you speak the language
you might have more fans in the main target demographic thus
offering you more opportunities to receive sponsors
dedicated to the main so like stuff like that like it it
seems like super simple but like it's like something you
have to be incredibly committed to do um you don't even have
to be like super fluent you could be like semi-fluent and
that is fine it just helps you in the long run um anyway you
have to have and learning language is incredibly difficult
and it's more so of like you just have to be like very
dedicated to doing so and networking also benefits because
you can reach out to like different fan bases and stuff like
that like by knowing because like obviously uh the English
fan base might be different from other language speaking fan
bases so the more you know the more beneficial it is to you
also but if you are like doing trying to cater to both fan
bases you need to be able to balance this so like you have
to be able to the hardest part is being able to balance
speaking languages for different audience basis because you
have to make sure like one audience doesn't feel left out
over the other so you have to be able to balance this very
well as well because you're gonna like you know some people
are gonna feel left out and you can't stop that people are
gonna feel left out like but you have to be able to make
sure that you're not catering to one side more than the
other so you have to find like a healthy balance my
suggestions on these is just maybe have like one stream a
week dedicated to speaking that language just to keep up
with like nurturing that fan base or like I feel like yeah
just to be able to like have like one or two streams a week
just dedicated to that just dedicate to that and another
thing is you don't need to worry about like big picture and
legal stuff what I meant by that is that when you're in a
company So as an indie, what I've noticed is that as an
indie, when you get more like merch collaborations, like
offers and deals, there's like contracts and negotiations
that you have to be involved in.
And because of that, you also have to obviously read those
contracts of like the merch negotiations or like sponsor
stuff.
You have to be able to read the contracts.
But when you're in a company, you don't really have to
worry.
that much about the big picture stuff because obviously the
company will make sure it wouldn't like hurt them regarding
like sponsors and merch stuff so like you put your trust in
that but when you're as an indie you have to make sure that
like even if your manager is reading as an indie even your
manager is reading that you have to read it yourself as well
because what the manager is doing doesn't necessarily mean
that that is what you want so you have to be able to read
your contracts and negotiate for things you want and that's
also obviously like a lot of work
anyway another one obviously is like 3d obviously companies
are very well experienced with having doing 3ds and having
3d done like they have all the experience and I would say
people in Japan, companies in Japan, have the most
experience with doing VTuber 3D stuff because, you know,
they've been doing, they've, like, perfected it type deal.
They perfected it, and I feel like in NA, a lot of companies
in NA are still playing catch-up when it comes to what JP
companies have done, or not just JP companies, but JP
Indies, too.
Indies in Japan also have, a lot of studios in japan are
very well versed in doing anime 3ds and they are still doing
catch-up so there's still a lot of time like there's still a
lot of catch-up it's also a lot of work
3d in general is a lot of work so uh but that's like one
thing that can offer as an indie you might not be able to
have that opportunity because as an indie um getting a
studio that's able to be able to handle all of that having
the assets made as well the thing about like come like
Japanese companies and Japanese like 3d tech is that a lot
of them have already have assets made from the past that you
can use um so they're always keeping assets that can help
benefit them more in the future um it's a lot of money
invested and they've already invested so much money that's
why like it is much more difficult as an indie and this if
you're really looking forward to an indie to being doing 3d
and stuff there's a reason why you want to join company and
finally sponsors um it's easier you don't have to reach out
for sponsors like a lot of times you don't have to make a
fucking deck like okay so you guys don't know you have to
have a pitch deck main as an indie but like for sponsors the
company already provide well like your company will be
working on finding these sponsors for you and uh so we don't
know what pitch deck is is basically a pitch deck is to
basically uh like a thing that you send to companies to like
business companies or sponsors or brand deals to like
advertise yourself and it's like as an indie you should have
that one main because like that is your way of like
advertising yourself as like a portfolio to advertise
yourself to like other companies but when you're part of a
company you don't have to worry about that your company will
be doing all that and they'll be picking people who they
want to do to represent particular brands and stuff like
that like you don't have to worry about anything you get
sponsored you'll just be pleasantly surprised like now
things to be aware of Number one, you're like, I don't know,
things that you need to be aware of.
Because if these things are not Gucci with you, then you're
going to have a rough time.
So, so if you are not cool with any of these things, you're
going to have a really rough time.
so one of them is permissions obviously uh when you're in a
company it doesn't even matter even if you're an na company
and even if you're like an na company this is like one of
the things you have to worry about the most because like
because you're not really safe
because they see you as corpa so you're not really safe in
general um and and they're more yeah companies are more um
more like looked at regarding perms it doesn't matter what
country you're in uh it really if you want to be really
smart about it if you're in from na you want to be really
smart on it just play na games but when you start playing
games or like try to do stuff outside of na that's when
things messy you might have fair use laws but you're part of
but even then that's not really gonna protect you um when
you're playing things or doing things else and the country
of origin is not america or canada or just not na so like i
said you need permission for things music games and others
what do you mean by others graphics pictures images videos
everything if you think showing pictures of something if you
guys didn't know um so there's like a lot of like many
things that a lot of like companies are like really strict
about like one of the i like i can give like so many like
famous examples but i won't because i don't want to get in
trouble but if you look hard enough like you can find them
And obviously, like some of the things that obviously you
should be like, you guys didn't know, like you can't make
like fan products of Sanrio stuff because they're very
strict regarding like fan products of like Sanrio things.
So like stuff like this, you can easily get stuff taking
down if you put like, I don't know, some like Hello Kitty
stuff that wasn't made by Sanrio.
Like you made your own Hello Kitty product, they will try
and take it down.
because like it's not made by them and stuff like that you
have to be worried it's not just music and games there's so
many other things to worry about and you might not be happy
that you can't get the permission that you want for stuff
certain things and uh you're very restricted on the games
you can play and like obviously music as well so like um uh
maybe like uh uh maybe some game companies don't give you
explicit permission and stuff like that so there's some
things like this to worry about you might maybe this is like
your favorite game of all time you really want to play it
like you really want to stream it but you can't and you have
to be able to accept that someone says is this only for
japanese companies no a lot of like smaller companies in NA
have to deal with that too because they don't want to worry
about like because like maybe if it's an NA game that's fine
if it's an NA developer and publisher then like you know
that's fine but if you're trying to do something that's
outside of NA then it's more of a risk and obviously when I
say other like someone said what about mods stuff like that
you have to get the permission from the original creator
usually some of them would say no
so but you have to have an explicit permit explicit
permissions for stuff like that so um so like it doesn't
matter like mods stuff like that like fan translations like
you have to worry about things like that obviously like i
said certain restrictions are to follow like not only just
with games and everything is how you handle yourself and
maybe like you're not allowed to do certain things or uh say
certain things because like you represent the company and
you have to be aware what you say and how you act because
what you do doesn't just reflect yourself but the whole
company so you have to be aware that your stance and actions
reflect the company's values your image and beliefs are tied
to the company so like you have to be very aware and if you
join a company in a lot of things.
You cannot, it's, it's, because like, you don't want it to
hurt yourself in the long run.
So you have to be incredibly neutral.
You have to be sure of, like, when you say things, of, like,
I like this thing that it's safe to say.
Like, that's what you have, because you're representing, now
you're not representing yourself.
It doesn't matter if that's your own opinion.
You represent the company.
So it doesn't matter.
You have to be neutral.
You're here to entertain.
You're like, you have to be like incredible.
You have to be safe and everything.
Um, and even then, if you are an indie that's planning to
join a company, you have to make sure you're like, I guess
like brand friendly type deal.
You have to be like brand friendly because like what you say
on the internet is forever.
It doesn't matter if it's like, oh, that was before, before
then, you know.
What you say on the internet is forever, so you have to be
sure that, like, you know, you're pretty much, like, your,
your, like, internet history is, like, okay.
Yes, the internet never forgets.
And then, obviously, another thing is juggling your schedule
regarding overlaps.
You don't want to over...
You want to be respectful to other people's schedules.
So, like, maybe, like, oh, this person's going to have a
sponsor stream at that time.
I don't want to overlap it.
I'm going to make sure to rate into the sponsor stream.
Because, like, how well they do in sponsors might mean,
like, the sponsor would want to do more with us.
So stuff like that.
You have to be very smart in how you arrange your schedule
and everything.
So you have to be sure that, like, that you're, like,
helping.
everybody not just yourself you can't just focus on yourself
you have to be sure that you're helping everybody if
everybody if if everybody grows that's a good thing you're a
team player so so it's very frustrating especially when
you're like oh i really want to do at this time slot but you
have to be a team player because you have to make sure that
everybody is is like going well so that in the long run you
will go well you will do well in the long run for everybody
um and it's all about like working together type deal uh so
and obviously like i said like percentage cuts taken i think
that's like very self-explanatory when you're working for a
company it doesn't necessarily mean you obviously like they
take a percentage so because they're like funding some
things they're helping you in some stuff they are arranging
things for you and stuff like that so it's obvious so that
is why people would want to join a company and those are the
pros and like what you have to be aware of, of what you have
to do.
So now you're running.
Okay, what about an indie?
So as an indie, basically it's like opposite of obviously a
lot of stuff I said regarding company.
So as an indie, like I said, there's more freedom what you
can do.
You're an indie.
There's so much more freedom.
There's a lot more.
Yay.
you have all the creative control on everything you do and
how you want your channel to be and you get to keep a
hundred percent what you make because you're by yourself
you're an indie like i think sorry i accidentally smacked
something so uh frank's taking the super chat thank you
thank you take this 100 percent also i Just realized I never
asked you guys how the sound was.
I hope the sound has been okay so far.
Hey, I hope the BGM has been like okay.
It's not too loud.
It's a bit low.
Okay, that's great.
That's fine.
You just want to listen to my voice anyway.
Why do you guys want to listen to that BGM?
It's all about the information I give you.
okay i'll boost it a little higher all right i'll give you
guys i'll give it a little higher all right so anyway as i
was saying um and your networking connection stays with you
so like you don't have to like you know everything your
connections and all of that directly goes to you it's not
that correctly from the company you know you don't have your
connections from the company you have the connections from
yourself so everything just funnels to you um and And then
you get to create the merchandise you want to make and guide
the production.
So, like I said, the thing about being an indie is just
everything is up to you.
How you want to make your career.
But, of course, with more freedom comes more risk.
So, because of that, you're opening yourself up legally to
more risk that you might not be prepared of.
So, like, obviously, like, scams, stuff like that.
And you have to, you have to like make sure, sure you have
to have a, depending on how big you are as a content creator
or a VTuber.
Or if you want to try and get to learn these things, you
will eventually have to have a business lawyer that can help
you look over contracts.
And especially regarding like, you don't want to be taking
advantage when it comes to like sponsors and brand deals.
You want to accidentally take a bad sponsor.
So there's like, there's like liability and stuff like that.
So you have to have a business lawyer that's there to read
your contracts and be able to like help you with stuff like
this.
So you also have to work harder when it comes to networking
and branding because it all comes down to you.
Obviously you don't have the company brand to like help you
with getting no people or with networking and branding.
You have to do all this yourself.
yourself and then you have to be smarter with this branding
and doing what is meta like you can't unless you want to be
niche but niche is also harder variety is an easier route
versus niche streaming because niche streaming when you're
doing niche streaming they you're restricted to that certain
niche you can't really branch out because the moment you
branch out your viewership will not follow you it doesn't
matter if you're like no they love me your viewership most
likely will just find another streamer that might be
streaming that particular niche so you don't want to cater
it's it's better for long-term streaming to be a variety
streamer because when that niche dies you are you are in
trouble you have to really like figure out what to do
fucking dedicated fan base but that in itself is also very
difficult so like like someone said if you only stream that
one thing those viewers will only show up for that one thing
so you have to it's long term wise variety is better for you
long term um even though it's harder to get started variety
is better to to have versus uh versus like beating a niche
And when you're in a company, you can go niche easier.
But because, like, you're under the company brand.
So, like, there are viewers that would be like, oh, I love
just watching people in this company.
So, like, it doesn't matter for you if you're a niche in a
company.
But when you're a niche as an indie, it affects a lot more.
Britt, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
purpose for games cover etc or is it unnecessary as an indie
if you're doing reaction content i would highly suggest
don't risk it on your channel or put it on twitch if you
want to do a reaction content just do it on twitch and then
like and that way and then like edit in a way that has that
benefits fair use.
Like, I would say that, like, if it benefits, and if you're
going to react to something and you think that you can
upload it on your channel, make sure the thing you're
reacting to is something within NA and not, like, outside of
NA.
Because then, if it's outside of NA, it's harder because,
you know, some countries might not have fair use laws.
regarding games music covers i would say cover songs um look
up song permissions if you're doing japanese covers look up
song terms for like japanese songs because like they have
the right to take down your song if you don't have proper
permissions um and if you're doing like maybe if uh and then
also like English songs they might get copyright claimed but
like or like but it doesn't affect your channel stuff like
that they'll just take the revenue if you're okay with your
music having your revenue taken um then that's fine
that's uh that's that it's okay because the most common
factor is like na songs like english songs it's mostly like
they just they just give you like a copyright claim where
they just take your revenue and unless you're just there to
like have views that's okay but if you actually want money
from doing cover songs um then you have to make sure that
like that particular song you're is okay perms-wise that you
won't get claimed like that's it um what else uh but yeah as
i said you have to follow as meta so fear of missing out
games so you saw me like a difficult what was it supermarket
simulator uh what's it the climbing game um stuff like that
you have to be honest the moment you realize it is the
streaming game.
You have to be on that shit.
It's that's it.
Because people want to watch those games and that's really,
you have to flavor up that week.
So you have to make sure you play it because you don't want
to miss out.
It's all about the meta.
And how do I figure out?
what's flavor of the month streams you literally look at the
biggest streamers out there that do variety and they're on
that shit the moment it releases how what's an easier way if
you don't know which streamer to watch go on twitch and look
at most popular game being streamed right now and that's how
you fought that is how i found out supermarket simulator and
the climbing game I literally go like I was like on Twitch
and I saw I was like, wait, what's this?
Everybody's streaming it.
All the flesh tubers are streaming it.
I was like, wow, this is clearly the streamer game.
So like I decided to play it because I was like, if people
really enjoy it, if a lot of people are watching it, clearly
it's a very entertaining game.
And then there's some games that doesn't matter.
There's some games like Outer Wilds.
I highly recommend streaming games such as Outer Wilds
because those games are like...
Games that have discord servers dedicated to it
And it's basically like Um, I talked about this before But
there's like games that have like cult fandoms So like outer
wilds is one of those games Where there's a discord server
dedicated to like finding streamers That are streaming outer
wilds Because they want to chase the high that outer wilds
gave them because they want to live vicariously through the
streamer streaming outer wilds so like yeah souls games and
outer wilds are some of these games or undertale too souls
games undertale and outer wilds are one of these games that
are really well-known streamer games because there are
servers dedicated to fighting other streamers that are
streaming that game because they want to live vicariously
through that game so if you're starting out these are like
some of the fucking they're they're the reason why they're
called stream games they're the reason why they're called
the streamer meta or the stream games and every fucking
streamer it doesn't matter what streamer you are it doesn't
matter if you're a vtuber or a flesh tuber or like whatever
content creator you are they love that shit and also gotcha
game but Like, if you're starting out, I would, I don't
know, I feel like you should invest your money unless you
want to be a gotcha streamer, but like, and you think you're
going to have your investment pay off later, and or you're
really fucking passionate about gotcha, but you're starting
out, a lot of your money is going to be spent on reinvesting
in your channel.
So like, that's why I was like avoiding gotcha, because
like, because you're investing on the gotcha instead of the
channel.
So, but if you're really passionate about gotcha, then feel
free to do gotcha.
Like, I'm not going to restrict you.
Anyway, so by the way, I have like 17 slides and I realized
we're Some of them are like really fast I think I think this
these two were like my longest slides But I hope it's been
like informative so far I hope this has been like
informative for you guys And like good advice Alright
auditioning obviously i won't be giving out audition secrets
um but like i've talked about this before um if you guys
look hard enough you guys can find an archive but like when
i got to when i passed the first round i researched a lot
and i had a 10 page document um going in to round two i um i
went obviously like the first stage would be like submitting
a video audition of stuff like that and then when i realized
my video audition passed i made a 10 page document detailing
like everything about preparing myself to the next round and
i was very i i like worked very hard on that and all in
there was like research and stuff like that um obviously i
can't give out my document but i can give you advice on how
to look research similar ways um There's lots of resources
out there from members within companies that reveal very
crucial audition advice and insight onto the interviews and
the audition tapes.
Like, if you look hard enough, you can actually find
members, not just like, you know, like members from
different branches that talk about specific info regarding
the audition stage.
looked at twitter and youtube in different languages to find
audition interview questions so like i highly recommend you
guys if you want to audition and a lot of times i would
believe the audition questions would be like super similar
like because it's like how many different types of questions
can you ask about vtubing so it doesn't matter So, like,
it's like stuff like that.
And then when you're doing your application, you have to
find your niche and main character type that you want to
play because they're trying to find a character for you.
They're trying to figure out, like, what will you bring?
Will you have, will you be the same personality that they
have five times?
Like, they already have?
Or will you be a new personality?
will you be a personality that has that is similar to like
one of their popular talents and they want to try and like
you know have another talent that is just as popular stuff
like that so you got to figure out what you're bringing and
like how to market yourself type deal and um you just have
to figure out like what you're bringing to the table and we
have to know that like there's more competition now because
VTubing is still is growing and like there's a lot of people
that want to be want this to be their big break a lot of
like hidden gems that want this to be like uh uh just want
this to be like the thing that you know that's gonna like
make them famous so there's more competition now so
standards and quality are higher what I submitted back then
as a video audition might not have fucking worked later on
if I try it on like try it now like it will not I personally
think it will not work so like obviously the quality wise
might be a lot higher depending on what type of company you
want to apply for it um it's definitely must have changed I
would assume has changed because the market is bigger now
and the competition is a lot higher and if you really really
really want to be in the uh no matter what company you want
to be a company uh vtuber don't be afraid of applying over
and over and over and over again until you make it in like
if you like most likely you might get ghosted not ghosted
but like usually if you're rejected on the first round, you
wouldn't even get an email.
So, like, and there's guidelines being like, if we don't
reply back within like X amount of months, try again.
Just try again.
Just keep submitting.
A lot of people would be like, I just kept submitting until
it worked.
And like, at that point, if you really want to join, just
keep submitting.
But also don't slack off on, like, you know, streaming as an
indie.
Just keep going as an indie.
And keep going as an indie and keep submitting.
That's really it.
So, you just have to keep taking your shots.
And that is really auditioning.
Um, equipment.
All right.
Number one.
Audio is so fucking important.
I will not watch a stream if I hear shitty audio quality.
That is like 100% for me.
This is my opinion.
But like, I will turn off a stream if the audio is this
fucking shit.
Like, like, like, That shit is so important.
Audio, that fucking shit is so important.
So remember to have good audio.
Like, if the first thing you're going to invest, please
invest in a microphone, a good quality mic.
And it is very, very...
Okay, I started out with a cheap $1 mic because I didn't
care.
when I used to live in Asia.
So, like, I was like, I just wanted a mic to communicate
with my teammates.
It wasn't about streaming, which I later used for streaming.
But I was, like, streaming, like, Overwatch.
So, like, it didn't really matter that much for me.
So, like, later on, when I got a little bit more serious, I
upgraded to a Blue Yeti.
Because Blue Yeti at that time was, like, a budget.
but it's still pretty expensive when you're starting out
like I know it says budget but like it's still like a pricey
microphone and it's actually like a good starting out mic if
you want to earn the snowball honestly like Yeti products
but I went with Blue Yeti but obviously a cheaper
alternative will be the snowball um but yes when i started
getting more serious later on but yes you want to be a
vtuber it's a huge investment similar with flesh tubing you
have to have like you know like the camera and stuff like
that it's a huge investment and obviously like uh you have
to be willing to put money onto this doesn't matter skin
suit rigging all that stuff you have to be willing to invest
in all of least in not all of these but like if you want to
like have a career you have to be able to invest in this um
anyway anyway as i said audio if you're investing anything
if you don't want to invest too much at least invest in
better audio um like i said get a mixer i have it go go xlr
but that is baby mixer because i'm stupid
If you talk to audio people, they will be like, oh, don't
get the GoXLR, you know, about mixing.
But I am stupid.
And GoXLR is like baby's first mixer.
And it's for, like, stupid people like me.
Because it's like very...
What's the word?
It's very...
It's like very intuitive.
If you know how to use audio, I would suggest asking your
audio friends, like people who are in music, to recommend
you better mixers.
And what are mixers?
Mixers, make sure you don't fucking peek when you're
talking.
So when you're laughing, when you're screaming, stuff like
that, mixers is a way to make sure your audio doesn't peek.
It's nice.
When you're whispering, it's not fucking terrible.
You can mute stuff, but you have to.
Like, you can mute audio so that people can hear, but you
can hear, stuff like that.
So, like, that's what you can control your collab partners
and stuff.
You can control your collab partners' audio.
But that's why I go with the GoXLR.
It's very intuitive and very, like, also there's sound
effects, stuff like that, but that doesn't really matter to
me.
All I use the GoXLR to help me with, like, making sure for
collabs and making sure I don't peak when I, uh, when I,
like, talk too loud, or if I scream, stuff like that.
It just, it helps a lot.
It normalizes your audio.
Um, audio balancing is so fucking important.
Audio, you can use OBS audio filters, but it's not as good
as a mixer.
uh it's not as good um but like i said goxlr is baby's first
mixer and like all the audio people would fucking judge you
for using a goxlr but you're stupid like me that is all you
need like i do not have the brain capacity to fucking
research stuff like this or be able to use an actual real
mixer correctly like if you look at what real mixers look
like they look so fucking complicated, then I can't be
bothered.
So, so, obviously, other mixers are cheaper.
Like, the actual real ones.
But, but GoXLR is so good for babies like me.
There's just too many buttons!
I can't!
I can't handle it!
there's so many buttons and sliders what the does i don't
know i don't know i'm not an audio person i just stream
anyway um you have to ask around if you don't want to go and
go xlr you have to ask around um anyway so like i was saying
uh the reason why audio balancing is so important is that
when you are in the collab a lot of times not a lot of times
but there are some viewers that will only watch the streamer
that has the best audio balance so you might not be you know
they're like oh hey i want to hear everybody you know i want
to hear everybody i want to know what everybody's saying i
want to know what everybody's talking about so they want to
have want to go to a stream that has the best audio
balancing and they'll look at all the other streams in the
collab and be like oh this stream has the best audio
balancing i'm gonna watch this stream so i can um so i can
figure out um like i can hear everything and stuff so that
is why audio balancing is very important and i have an audio
guy i have an odd person that um i have a person that
watches my streams to make sure my my audio balancing is
good i personally have a person that looks at that person as
well they like work on music and stuff so i personally have
a music person to make sure everybody is balanced my sound
guy um and that's why i'll be like sound guy i will
sometimes look at discord because i would have them on
discord and they'll be like is the audio good and stuff like
that so uh that's what my sound guy does because i want to
make sure that everything is okay and that is very important
like i said there's viewers that will only watch a collab
stream with the person that has the best audio balancing.
It's all about maximizing the comfort of the viewer.
So, you know, you can ask a friend to be like, hey, can you
check my stream?
If you don't have like a person really to like really check
on your audio, you can ask a friend.
Like, don't ask chat because chat is not a hive mind.
You'd be like, hey, chat how's the audio never fully trust
chat because chat is not a hype mind and it really depends
on their headphones on whether or not like the audio is good
some people say yes some people say no and then you don't
know who to listen to find one person you trust very much to
not to to monitor your audio and just monitor your audio for
the first like one minute to And then at that point, then
you can, they don't have to be there.
They can be, if they want to, they can be there.
But like, you know, if you're asking a friend, you don't
want to force them.
I can literally see my baby go XLR.
Tell me that I'm not muted.
This is why you get a mixer, too.
So some people can't troll you.
Also, TV, thank you for the five gift and shifts.
Thank you, thank you.
So, so having it.
sound person dedicated to monitoring your balance is like
really helpful especially long term um because like i said
it really affects it anyway so i gave you guys my timeline
of like what the microphones i use so i use a cheap one
dollar mic then i evolved to a blue yeti and then i used an
at 2020 and then i moved on to the sure sm7b the sure sm7b
is my current microphone that i use at the moment i'm
planning on maybe in the future to upgrade my microphone
again but only more so of like whenever i get my pc upgraded
um i will upgrade my microphone as well so for now we're i'm
keeping my sure mic at the moment um but this is like my
timeline of everything um if you are a singer if you want to
get started into singing these are not singing microphones
this.
These are not singing microphones.
These are podcast microphones.
So if you want to sing, I would suggest asking your fellow
friends who are singers or research singing microphones
because there is like singing microphones are way different.
I would highly suggest not singing with these microphones.
you need a different mic I personally don't remember what
mics you need because um when I sing when I record things I
just go to a studio um or I just like and then and then I or
I sing with my sure microphone because I don't care um it's
the studio or my sure microphone because I'm not I don't
care as much but if you're serious get a actual singing mic
and like research on that I can't give you the research for
that because I don't know that's really really I can say
about like microphones everything else in my opinion is just
a bonus everything else like as long as you have good like
when you're starting out think all the other stuff you can
just invest in the future when you have the money but if you
want to start your career i would the main thing you focus
on investment wise is the audio everything else bonus it
doesn't matter until you get like actually make money anyway
um for example like this is my other equipment i have three
monitors it's for efficiency wise so i can reach out on on
one of the monitors my right monitor that's vertical and
then i have obs and other browsers and stuff uh on my left i
have my main content if it's a game in the center monitor so
like the game will be in the center and then right now my my
notes is in the center so i can read it and everything so um
so that is like why i have three microphones if you want to
get an iphone i would highly suggest an iphone x or higher
because that is the best for facial tracking due to the
inbuilt facial tracking when it comes to v-tubing so i would
highly suggest if you want really good like really good skin
suits and iphone x or higher um obviously tanky pc or dual
pc setup a dual pc setup means you don't have to have
incredible parts like you don't have to have like oh sorry i
mean three monitors i don't know what said but I meant three
monitors I meant three I don't know that say three PCs I
meant three monitors you can either have an incredibly tanky
PC or you have a dual PC set up dual PC set up doesn't
require you to have like really insane parts because it
helps like one PC will be used for streaming and then the
other PC will be used for games or like other stuff so like
that's really helps is that vtubing apps take up a lot
sometimes and plus whatever game you're streaming.
Sometimes you're like, oh, why are you lagging?
Why are you losing frames?
I streamed this game.
I don't have any issues with it.
But we also have like us on the screen.
So that takes up a lot of space too.
So that is why when you're vtubing, it requires more
resources.
So I highly suggest if you invest on a better PC invest in
dual pc setup and also a lot of the current games are
fucking terribly optimized
optimization is shit so uh so you have to worry about that
too so like that's why like you just you just had to have a
better optim you just had to have a better pc now and my
headphones is the 70 pro I don't know that matters I don't
know anything about headphones I asked one sound guy about
it and then they like recommended this headphone so then I
bought it uh but like I honestly have like I don't know if
you can try and copy my headphones too I also have fiber
internet because my niche in a way I'm more of a variety
streamer but like I do have like a FPS.
By the way, I'm going to be in Twitch Rivals for Apex
Legends next week.
So, great segue.
But ping really matters to me.
So, that's why I have fiber internet.
But, obviously, like, really, not every place has fiber
internet.
But, yes, anyway.
Alright, so that is the equipment.
I hope that is helpful regarding equipment-wise.
all right twitch versus youtube okay i know like it's like
very brief but i also have like more stuff to say about it
as well so twitch versus youtube should you stream on twitch
should you do youtube or should you multi-stream um the
thing okay so i am primarily on youtube is because i'm used
to it um i also i like having set schedules um i don't like
streaming whatever I want because uh I'm super fucking
indecisive I like knowing what I'm doing I used to not but
then now I'm like I like knowing what I'm going to do um so
like because it helps me plan my day and time uh anyway like
I said for Twitch the biggest benefits of Twitch is the
rating system uh which benefits you because if you're
starting out raids help so much with growing your presence
and channel so youtube has raids but like it's not as
utilized as twitch because it's harder to find people to
raid because like the youtube rating system is uh is like
not as usable i guess in a way it's it's like It benefits
companies more than it benefits individuals for YouTube.
But on Twitch, it benefits, you know, everybody, like
individuals.
Like, if you're an indie, Twitch rating benefits more so
than YouTube rating.
Because, like, there's not a lot of VTubers on YouTube as an
indie.
And it's harder for discoverability on YouTube versus
Twitch.
The thing about Twitch is that there is, like, an option to,
look for like lower viewed streamers on twitch to find raids
like there are moments when like you know bigger content
creators on twitch will go to a category the thing about
youtube you can't go to a category and you know find people
you want to raid and also like um not everybody has the
option on um if you guys don't know if you're starting out
on youtube the rating is off automatically YouTube rating.
On Twitch, it's on automatically.
So, like, on Twitch, you can, like, go to a category and be
like, I want to rate somebody in this category.
And then you can, you know, browse through and be like, oh,
I want to rate somebody in the VTuber category.
And then you'll be like, oh, this person doesn't have,
doesn't have, like, a lot of, like, people, you know.
Oh, did I spell it wrong?
Sorry, I can't be bothered to fix it.
But you can go to the category and be like, oh, hey, this
person doesn't have a lot of viewers.
I'm going to rate them.
There's a lot of success stories like that.
For example, NiceWig blew up because Dizzy, and for those
who don't know Apex, I'm just going to do Apex terms.
The reason why NiceWig blew up was because Dizzy was
browsing through Apex Twitch streamers and found NiceWig on
Twitch streaming in the Apex category.
Nizzi at the time was the Apex streamer.
Was like the biggest Apex streamer at that time.
And he raided NiceWig.
And NiceWig took that big luck opportunity.
And rode it to where he is now.
And it's stuff like that.
Like now NiceWig is like one of like the biggest known Apex
streamer out there.
He's like the official Bcaster for ALGS.
that so like that is why when you're starting out and you
want to hit the easiest way to hit your biggest break is on
twitch maybe later on you can move to youtube but i think if
you're starting out this is na by the way na if you're
starting out i don't know for other countries but you're
starting out i would say twitch is your biggest bet in terms
of making it on youtube it is a lot there's less
discoverability as a YouTuber, as an indie YouTuber, it's a
lot harder.
And more so, streaming is a Twitch thing for NA people.
For English-speaking audiences, if you're a streamer, you're
on Twitch.
YouTube is still trying to figure this out for NA.
I was just lucky to be able to do YouTube.
because I already have an audience established on YouTube.
So it's a lot easier.
It's a lot easier to get started.
It's better to start on Twitch and then move on to YouTube
because I think long-term YouTube is better monetary wise
because you have everything in one channel.
You have the VODs.
You have videos.
Everything is one channel.
Usually, you just have the live stream, and then you upload
it, edited versions of your live stream to your YouTube
channel if you want to.
Twitch is just streaming.
Usually people don't watch VODs on Twitch.
People will watch edited content on YouTube of your Twitch
VODs.
So, that is why, like, long term, I feel like YouTube is
just better long term in general.
If you want to do long term wise.
anyone if you're a twitch streamer anyone having presence on
youtube have your vods edit it into highlights don't just
upload vods because like sometimes people can't fucking
watch two hours of vods
we all have short attention spans these days have a vod
channel too if you really want to and want to keep the vods
the vod just keep it i don't know but if you really want to
have a presence on youtube upload edited versions of the
edited highlights of your vod yes people would rather watch
edit highlights than the fucking two to three hour video uh
if you upload your vods have a separate vod channel the
reason why i don't upload my vods my twitch vods onto my
youtube channel my main one is that that affects my
algorithm so much because I know personally because I'm like
that too that not a lot of people would want to watch like
three hour plus of something that's already happened they
rather watch it live and because of that I have a separate
VOD channel because I know if the VOD performs not as good
as my other stuff it affects my algorithm and Like, what the
fuck?
YouTube would be like, whoa, what happened there, Doki?
Why is your channel fucking tanking from this one video?
And I had to separate it because I know my channels are the
meta and you have to have it separate.
Like, if I'm going to upload a video, it would be
highlights.
and that's the way you have to appease the algorithm it's
all about playing the algorithm all right but what about
multi-stream yes you can multi-stream it's a very popular
method right now especially in na i don't think like other
countries people are doing multi-streams it's mostly uh
because like it's mostly an na thing i personally don't do
multi-streams the audience.
I don't like, because you can only have one chat up there,
and like, I don't like, I personally don't like, this is my
own personal preference, and that is why I don't
multi-stream, because I don't like splitting the audiences,
and, like, I don't like cultivating different cultures of
viewerships, because, um, because, like, Twitch culture is
different from YouTube culture and then if you choose if you
multi-stream you only have one chat up and um and then
obviously if you have one particular chat up over the other
more people will go on to that stream because people would
be like oh you're gonna be paying attention to that chat so
i rather pay attention to one singular chat from one
platform and just juggle i make one my main and the other
different So, like, that is why I, uh, I, like, I don't do
multi-stream, but I know that others do multi-stream because
it's really good for growth on both platforms.
You don't know which platform is your main platform and you
want to grow as a creator.
You do small, if you're a small streamer, you can do both
because it's very good for growth.
I don't do both because, like, I particular, on nurturing
one community and one like focus on like one community
versus like trying to trying to split myself too much uh
because i do better uh focusing on one thing rather than
like two things because i'm stupid as hell that
is why obviously as a newer streamer multi-streaming is good
for you i would personally say multi-streaming would be a
good benefit for you but like uh growth wise twitch is a way
to go for growth wise if you're a smaller streamer uh
um anyway um also as a twitch streamer there is like
different cultures like i said there's different like viewer
culture and streaming cultures on youtube there's a lot of
things you have to was like one of the things that like was
the most stressful for me it was because like adjusting to
this i need a schedule before before going like more serious
and vtubing i would just stream whatever the fuck i want i
didn't have a schedule i didn't make thumbnails and i didn't
plan anything i just streamed but um when you're getting
serious on youtube youtube viewers youtube They like
schedules.
They like thumbnails and they like it when you plan stuff.
But also, you have to realize that because you have a
schedule, viewers will pick and choose what they want to
watch.
So, like, you know, sometimes you stream something.
You know they're going to stream this, but it's not
something they want to watch so they don't show up.
You have more of an inconsistent, like, concurrent viewers.
uh because like you know they don't want to watch it
well on twitch viewers are like they don't care no they do
care they do care but like a lot of times when you're
watching you're on twitch when you're watching they don't
really have they do play whatever the fuck they just go like
i'm today i want to play this and then i gotta swap to that
and now i'm gonna do this and now do that there's no there's
no like actual like you don't know what's gonna happen that
type deal um but you're always there you're just there
you're there for them type deal you don't care what they're
doing you just want to be there like so like so like twitch
viewers they're more so like whoa what's gonna happen it's
more we're just here we're just here uh it's very
unpredictable We're just here.
But then, like, YouTube, they're like, oh, they're going to
play this.
I don't really want to watch that.
So I guess I'll just miss it.
Like, it's more so, like, I'm not really into that game.
I'm just going to watch something else.
You know, like.
Like, it's stuff like that.
You're just, but Twitter, you're like, I'm just happy to be
here.
So, oh shit, chat disconnected.
Am I still alive?
My chat disconnected.
Oh, shit, okay, I'm back on.
Did I, was I still alive?
I don't know.
My chat disconnected.
Oh, I was.
Okay, for some reason, my chat disconnected.
So I was like, whoa, am I still alive?
Okay, anyway, that's basically it.
So you have to be aware, like, even so.
You're still cultivating a fan base on YouTube.
But, like, Twitch viewers, like, YouTube viewers have an
excuse.
Twitch viewers don't have an excuse to not watch you.
Because they're like, what if I miss an important thing
that's going to happen?
Because I wasn't there.
I don't know what's happening.
it's like you don't know they don't know they don't know
they have to be there because they're like what if oh my god
what if she's just gonna play my favorite game and i'm gonna
miss out yeah the fear of missing out yeah what if i miss a
game that oh my god she's gonna play a game that i really
like i don't know that but what if she does like you don't
know so you're you're you're there you're there no matter
what game you're playing and then uh the fear of missing out
but youtube you're like she's gonna play that i hate that
game i'm not gonna show up
I personally like structure more I don't like randomly
picking games and stuff because like I just want to focus on
one thing um I just want to focus on one thing and then be
good with that like I I'm I don't I don't like I don't I
like more of a structure because I'm I'm very indecisive and
I just know what I'm doing.
I am super indecisive in general.
And then there's like memberships and stuff like that.
Like in Twitch the thing is a lot of Twitch streamers they
have Discord servers but like Discord servers for like which
is like the substitute of the membership stuff on YouTube.
YouTube offers memberships.
On Twitch you don't have to there's like subs but You're not
required, you're not like incentivized to have like, you
know, sub only streams, stuff like that.
In YouTube, you are, because like it is a benefit to be a
YouTube member.
There's more exclusivity being a member.
There's more stuff to it.
There's a different culture on Twitch.
Subs don't have like exclusivity on there.
There's no exclusive stuff other than like Discord servers.
I know like a lot of like Twitch VTubers, a lot of Twitch
content creators.
They have, like, a Discord server dedicated to be, like, the
memberships stuff on YouTube.
So, it's more so of, like, and then there's the emotes
stuff.
You can use the emotes everywhere and stuff like that.
And it's more so of, like, obviously, when you're a YouTube
streamer, cater your, not cater, cultivate your membership
stuff.
Make it appealing.
Don't just have, like, nothing, really.
member streams every other week to have something and I have
like membership plans like exclusive membership stuff like
exclusive gaming sessions and exclusive like Minecraft
member server like stuff like that there's like exclusive
wallpapers that are being made um so that people want to
want to keep uh want to keep being a member so don't just
like make sure to have something there to make it worth
being a member as a twitch sub you don't really have like
twitch you don't really have like a like other than emotes
there's no like the twitch sub the appeal is the emotes it's
not like the like because you know youtube emotes you can't
use it you can only use it in one channel but twitch emotes
you can use it in every channel you can use it everywhere
that's the appeal uh if you're on a highly recommend if
you're going to be a twitch streamer to have good emotes
because sometimes people subscribe to the emotes i've had
that happen before there's been multiple cases of people um
just subscribing on twitch because they just want to use
cool emotes if you want to appeal to have good subs to have
like more subs on twitch have nice quality emotes and make
sure they're like memorable or stuff like that like make
sure like people would want to have it like they don't care
about your content They just want to have good memos Like
Some people actually do it It was a huge thing A couple of
years ago There would be streamers That were known as like
Oh my god They're like the bear emotes I only want them for
the bear emotes Like that's it They were known for like
their emotes That was it And like people actually did that
People actually just subscribed To have good emotes And like
If you really want to like If you really want to like appeal
to like more people then do that it's fine it's just another
way to like have a more uh stable like uh i guess like
stable income um all right anyway i think is that everything
i have uh everything i have for youtube i think that's
everything i have for youtube versus twitch All right, the
algorithm.
Woo!
I love the algorithm.
Yay.
All right.
Algorithm.
So, shorts.
If you're on YouTube, milk the shit out of shorts.
Shorts are being heavily pushed by YouTube for a while now.
I thought they would stop, but they're still doing it
because they want to take over TikTok.
that you know take we might not even have tick tock anymore
so youtube is like we're gonna be the next tick tock so
they're heavily pushing shorts at the moment um because of
that even streams by the way you might be seeing a lot of
people streaming shorts like like live streams in the shorts
category because like when you're browsing through like
short youtube shorts you can get like you like live streams
now too from like random people so like yeah a lot of
vertical streams It just shows up on your fucking algorithm.
It just shows up.
You just scroll through and then some streams show up too.
And it's really good for building the audience because
that's what the algorithm is pushing right now.
The meta is shorts.
Everybody just wants to watch on their phone.
Everyone just wants to watch on their phone now because I
don't know.
We just have very short attention spans these days.
We're not really helping ourselves.
Okay, but don't put all your eggs in that basket.
Because you can upload your shorts to TikTok and Instagram.
Apparently, Instagram reels are also blowing up now, too.
But, like, that's if you want to cater to the normies more.
Like, I would say, you can work on, like, Instagram reels.
If you really want to, like, cater more to, like, the
normies.
Because, like, all the normies are in Instagram.
now so i mean i think they're still using instagram i don't
know i haven't used instagram so fucking long uh but like uh
it's instagram reels um tick tock and youtube shorts there's
a lot of channels right now that are like one million to two
million like one million plus subscribers and all they do is
just shorts they don't don't upload any videos or like do
any live streams it's literally just shorts because that's
what youtube is pushing right now there's like i've seen i
was like watching looking at some of the channels that are
like um that are like they will upload videos but the videos
would have like 20k views or something but then the shorts
would be like 30 million and 40 million and they'll have
like 1 million plus subscribers it's because they only push
shorts I would highly suggest and highly recommend That you
do short You don't put everything on shorts You still stream
Just remember this stream Because you need to keep your
audience You stream and shorts You stream upload short What
I used to do Is that I would upload a short Every time I'm
not streaming Because like the YouTube algorithm so fucked
up that if you don't upload any of thing for a day they
would be like whoa that's a bad mark on your algorithm I'd
be like they'll be like you're not uploading now
so back then I would upload a short whenever I'm not
streaming because I would be like oh no now I can't keep up
the algorithm now I upload a short even if I'm streaming
because I want to keep a consistency because I'm just
starting out and right now I have like a huge boost in my
algorithm so I have to keep going and because of that I'm
keep going until like the algorithm boost has stagnated so
that is why I personally am uploading shorts even when I'm
streaming, I have three editors.
Each editor edits at least two shorts per week so I can keep
this consistent schedule.
That is because I am willing to, I have the money to invest
in it.
Obviously, not everybody has the money.
I have to edit it themselves and stuff like that.
I have three editors so they can, I don't want to overwork
one editor.
So I have three editors and I give them a chance to edit two
shorts per week.
If they don't want to do it, that is up to them.
they want to edit more that is up to them um but i i have i
let them because i don't want to overwork one editor so i
separate into three and i have a whole server set up for
them so that they they won't like overload each they won't
like overlap each other and that is why i can able to keep
the consistency of like having a short almost every day to
keep this algorithm boost because i have a fucking insane
algorithm boost right now.
Like I'm fucking everywhere apparently.
And that's what I mean when I said it's all about luck.
You can't just coast.
You have to know when you have the boost.
When you have the algorithm boost, you have to be consistent
regarding keeping this algorithm.
And that is why I've been trying to keep this algorithm up.
And that is why I have three editors to keep this up.
Oh, but like I said, you might see a lot of people streaming
short section because, yeah, like I said, the stream will be
fed into the short scrollers.
That's why everybody's streaming in a vertical format.
In a vertical format now.
Also, we're doing shorts.
I remember I saw on Twitter, how do I pick the moments?
I let my editors pick the clips because if they see a
good...
How did I find my editors?
I hire clippers.
That is why clipping is so good.
get noticed as an editor as an editor or like if you want to
get jobs as an editor be a clipper clip some of your
favorite vtubers clip some of your favorite content creators
because they know what's good content and that is why i
hired clippers because i hired some of these clippers some
of their videos I researched their videos and they have like
millions they've got like millions of views on their videos
or like they got like 500k views on the videos that they've
clipped themselves and then I was like and they would clip
me and I'd be like you're a good clipper I'm going to hire
you um and that is how I found my clippers my editors I
basically if you really want to try and get your name out
there just start clipping your favorite content creators
because that's how they research I don't normally pick like
random editors I um I clip somebody that watches me because
they know what's a good content that I bring but if you
can't afford to I highly suggest when you try we're like oh
but what if I'm making my own clips then um uh then look at
your chat and see which part has the biggest fan response
like chat response because usually because there's like a
there's like an analytic thing where you can see that so
like when you see an ally which one has the most like chat
engagement that is usually where the best content is to clip
because people would be like oh like oh like a lot of
chatters started
moment that must have been a good part and then you watch it
back like oh that is a good part i'm gonna edit this myself
um obviously learning to edit is like a skill i don't know
how to edit and that's why i pay people to do it i'm more of
a producer i am a producer more so of of like um being able
to do like editing and stuff like that i have i'm an idea
person um i i i am an idea person and I like to produce
things.
editing is really hard.
I can't really give much advice regarding editing because,
uh, Addy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here's my tuition.
I can't really do much regarding giving advice on editing.
So I really suggest, like, looking up, like, tutorials or,
like, asking around.
Uh, but, like, anyway, so, like, that is basically how I go
about with clipping, with, like, editing and stuff.
um there's another way to do like there's different types of
edits you can do right now since i am an indie i'm much more
free to experiment with my editing um it's more so of like
so you see like back then it was just mostly clips and like
animated clips now i'm more so experimenting with how my
shorts are done there's more so there's like story time
stuff uh story time is very popular If you really want to
blow up with shorts, story time is the best way to go.
Story time and anything to do with relatability is the way
to go.
If you have a story, that shit will do so well.
It's all about tangents, story time, and relatability with
the clips.
And that is like the clips that would blow up the most with
grinding shorts.
To blow up into like the normie spear.
Like it goes beyond just V-tubing.
um so people can be like she's just like me for real for
real if you look at my shorts my most popular shorts is the
um it's the one where i bought the sticker and the waking up
stuff like i'll be like oh i sleep i wake up i eat breakfast
i sleep and people be like oh my gosh she's so relatable
she's depressed i'm sorry i saw that so what if my comment
was like oh my god She sleeps so much.
She's so depressed.
It's so relatable I saw that I was like what the fuck anyway
That was like one of the comments I thought But like as I
was saying there's a lot it's all about like or like
something that's like so wrong like bait engagement or
something.
Like, cause like, I'd be like, you know, like one was like,
my dream sponsor is a Funko Pop.
And then I was like, yeah.
And then obviously people in the comments would be like,
what the fuck?
Why Funko?
Why not a Nendoroid?
And stuff like that.
Because like, you know, that gives comments and likes.
Also, it's still my dream sponsor because it's so fucking
funny.
Okay.
It's like the biggest endorsements you can get in the Normie
Spear.
And you're supposed to break the normie's fear.
It's so great idea.
It's a great idea.
Because people who don't know what the fuck you are will buy
Funko Pop.
Because Funko Pop collectors will only...
Don't give a fuck.
They'll collect anything.
They, like, just want to collect Funko.
They, like, have such a community.
Their community is all about collecting everything.
It's, like, it's so...
I don't know.
And that's why I could be, like, vtuber in that fucking
collection it's just smart it's so fucking smart like anyway
uh because like nendoid collectors nendoid collectors they
collect parts if you don't have a good part they don't care
because nendoid collectors they're not here they're here to
make new net they just want to want the parts and the faces
and stuff like that or like they're fans of the show like
there's but Nendroid collectors, like the hardcore
collectors, they're not collecting the figures, they're
collecting the Nendroid parts.
So they can mix and match.
But Funko Pop collectors, they collect everything.
They might be like, I don't know what that character is, but
I want it.
But I also love a nendroid too because that's also a dream
because they look amazing i used to be i used to be an
android collector not an android parts collector but like an
android collector like like like the not hardcore collector
of nendroids i would buy nendroids because i'd be like oh i
like i'd buy nendroids because i'd be like oh i like this i
like this um uh character i don't know what character this i
was like a funco pop version of an android collector because
i bought like that i bought an a nendroid where like the
character was riding on a bird thing i don't know what the
fuck who the fuck this character is i was like look at that
beautiful bird mount i want it
i still don't know what character it is i still don't know i
just thought it was so cool because i was like i've never
seen it before on a nendroid it was back then when like
nendroid have like those like second mount character things
and i was like that's so cool
no it wasn't final fantasy i have no idea anyway we're off
topic uh we're off topic right now
okay anyway fomo games the fear of missing out streamer
games i already explained about that already.
I already explained about like FOMO games, but it's, you
know, like I said, there's like, you don't want to miss out.
Lots of viewers don't want to miss out, so you have to play
them.
Great examples.
Chilla Arts games.
So many VTubers play Chilla Arts games because Chilla Arts
is like the epiphany of FOMO.
They don't want to miss out.
Rage gaming, too.
don't want to miss out because it's all reaction bating it's
there to bait reactions and they love making they love
seeing the reactions of like the vtuber streaming this
particular section or this vtuber that's why horror games is
so popular but you can't always do horror games Because if
you're always streaming horror games, then like, uh, then
like people get tired.
Unless that's your niche.
But even if that is your niche, you still have to be able to
balance it out.
Because people will just get, like, too much horror, you
know?
It's just be like, it's just like, oh, she's just gonna
scream at that part.
And then you're like, it's the same thing.
Like, oh, she's just gonna get jump scare.
It's just, you're just gonna get desensitized.
It's why horror streamers are...
Horror streamers were a niche.
It was meta because people love watching streamers scream.
But then the meta died.
It's all about the stream meta.
He used to say PewDiePie and Markiplier and Jacksepticeye.
They all used to stream horror stuff.
But now they don't.
They don't stream that much.
Like if you watch their streams, they like don't stream
horror that much anymore.
Because the meta died out.
They don't...
It's not the meta anymore.
PewDiePie is a great example of a content creator that knew
when to swap metas.
Like, he swapped so many times with metas because he knew
what was going to be the next meta.
He was like a reaction.
He fucking swapped a reaction content because he knew that's
what people wanted to watch.
And he was like, I would say like PewDiePie was one of the
first like starters.
of like reaction content like the one of the biggest people
that like knew what like like that like pioneered reaction
content because he knew that's what people wanted people
like reaction content that's what fucking rides the
algorithm and then it got it turned into something i don't
know and he does like vlogging now because he's he's a dad
now he's super chill he doesn't need to do anything he's
super fucking chill like he's a dad now he has so much money
like he doesn't have to he just does it for fun he
just does stuff for fun he doesn't have to care about the
meta anymore like he has the money to not care so like
that's like his plus side um and also comments and likes
commenting and liking is so beneficial it actually helps
boost the algorithm so if you like this that's why people
like comment and comment and like this video.
Um, I don't really say it because like, I don't know.
I don't want, it feels too normy.
I know it just feels too normy.
But it actually helps a lot.
It really does help the engagement.
Like I could end up saying, I'll be like, hey, at the end of
the VOD, I could be like, make sure to comment, like and
subscribe.
But like, I don't do it because I'm lazy.
Okay, to be fair, one of the main reasons why I don't do it
is because I'm fucking lazy.
But also...
it's a little cheesy and it's like super normy so that's why
that's why i don't really do it i don't tell people that
comment like and subscribe but it helps if you want to help
like an indie vtuber or like an indie or like a small
streamer comment and like and subscribe like comment and
like their videos like all their fucking vods and all
everything because it helps the algorithm a shit i don't
know why anyway so like i said follow the trends you guys
know what the newest fucking weird ass trend is i'm not
doing it because it's like it's pretty fucked up i don't
care that much i would follow like some trends if it seems
fun but i if it's like too much this is i just think it's
just too much i don't um but like the newest trend right now
is the green screen trend And that is like where, because it
like baits engagement.
It baits like, whoa, shock factor.
So like basically what they do is that there's a green
screen on their body.
And then you have like the gameplay with on their body.
So like that's the engagement bait.
And yeah, that's like the current trend.
It might change later, but that is the current trend.
You can say the NPC thing was a trend as well.
did you know 80% of my viewers are not subs did you guys
actually I think mine is like 20% I think 20% or like 10 to
20% my viewers are not subscribed so like I think that one
was mine um but yeah anyway thank you the super chat thank
you thank you spirit um um but the NPC stream is also a
trend it's a trend so you follow trends obviously it baits
engagement and it baits like uh like a shock like oh that's
something new oh my god they're doing something new i like
you're doing something funny something new oh my god ha ha
like stuff like that just follow trends and then songs songs
are really really good like if your cover song hits like a
million views whoa good for you congratulations it means you
have done really well it's really good because people some
people will subscribe to you because they really like your
singing like you they will put it on your playlist.
Also Spotify.
You can make so much money on Spotify.
If you just upload your song on Spotify.
I would heavily suggest if you have a fan base.
If you're starting a fan base as a singer or an Utaite or
Utaite.
You start uploading things on Spotify.
You can actually make a lot of money from Spotify if you
have enough songs or if you have enough exposure because
people will put it on repeat and like songs on Spotify on
repeat does make a decent amount of money and it's only uh
uh it's only like I know some people were like oh there's
like big streamers but you have to remember a lot of the
bigger streamers have other companies taking the cut of
those streams like the like big singers like the like the
what was it the billboard singers you know like like I'm
trying to think like if we talk about Taylor Swift's old
management company Taylor Swift if you guys don't know why
Taylor Swift is re-releasing her album.
It is because, uh, if she, the reason why, uh, Taylor Swift
is re-releasing her album is because her old album, um, is
owned by her old music label, and her old music label is,
um, is like, uh, uh, basically owns that song.
And because of that, she barely earns money from those old
her old music so like that's why you see like oh but all the
big music stars they don't earn that much but when you're
smaller music singer you actually earn a pretty decent
amount on spotify uh but you have to remember it's better if
you make original songs versus like cover songs to upload on
spotify because obviously a lot of artists might not let you
upload cover songs on spotify but you gotta have permission
from the artist to be so like it's better to if you have
original songs it actually can actually like make back your
money type deal on spotify because like it actually is very
uh beneficial to you as uh grow to grow as a singer um and
uh so like if you're a singer fucking do covers do so do as
many covers as you can original songs if you're a really
talented singer or if you're just just do it because it's so
good for your growth it is real it's just a lot of money
invested but if you want to market yourself as a singer this
is the way you have to go um this is the way you have to go
you have to you want to market yourself as that uh if singer
then sing exactly exactly uh so like a lot of people that
subscribe for like singers they just want to hear the songs
too so you have to be aware though that a lot of people that
subscribe to singers like singer vtubers they're just they
they listen to the songs they're just here to listen to the
song and they like put it on repeat over and over and over
and over again um but a lot of but then there's a lot of
vtubers that got big from singing cover songs and it's good
exposure if you have good cover songs there's so many like
amazing cover song singers that like um i love to listen to
that are that are like big big vtubers now like amalie i
have i used to have i have so many of her covers on my
playlist before like she became a vtuber before i became a
vtuber i would listen to her songs all the time on my
playlist because i loved cover songs in general i had so
many like i would primarily just listen to cover singers
because i i personally liked cover singers more than the
original and there's like so many of that in my playlist uh
but yeah like i said just make songs all right branding okay
this is like that's really very like in like a simple slide
i feel like this slide in general there's not really like
much to say about it but like
100% this is what I believe it this is 100% what I believe
it if you choose if you are an animal VTuber is the easiest
when it comes to branding because like animal VTubers are
like more recognizable than a human I would say that because
like there's like traits in there that are um that that are
there that makes you distinct from like uh from like
different other vtubers like you have like animal
characteristics all the more more famous vtubers have like
some animal characteristic about them because you can do
many things about it you can like make them as like you know
their alternate form is the animal itself or like you can
make like merch wise stuff merch merch and everything it's
like so good like regarding that and there's so many cat
girls out there so like you have to be like what makes you
more distinct from all the other cat girls you know you have
to have something that makes you more distinct than the
other cat girls you have to have like a a design trait a
unique silhouette but you can't have too unique of a
silhouette because people don't like it when it's too
fucking complicated um um and then an average viewer needs
to be able to pick you out very easily so branding is so
very important this is why i've been like i think i i don't
know i'm fucking i don't know what i'm gonna be doing for my
skin suit i don't know man that's how i feel at the moment
but my my new skin suit i don't know
I just hope like my it works I hope it works it was so hard
figuring out branding but like it's so important because
like merch and stuff too if you want okay long term branding
I would say long term branding because like I know there's a
lot of YouTubers that like swap models or change their
branding and stuff like that um but like if you want if you
like uh if you want to be more safe you keep the same brand
I say that as I'm getting a new skin suit but this like this
brand is like really old so like I have an excuse to upgrade
I technically I sort of have an excuse to upgrade my
branding because like this this skin suit is very old to be
fair my original branding is a tomato so like um it still
works But like, anyway, I would, to make it more simple and
to make it like more, I guess like easier for you, um, if
you already have a noticeable brand, I would suggest highly
to keep the same brand because it's such a huge, that's why
I'm scared.
This is, this is why I'm personally scared with my new skin
suit.
because um when you when you change brands you don't know if
people are gonna stay because maybe your old brand was like
very already very recognizable and people hate change people
really hate change and it also helps for the normie sphere
like average viewers outside of your community
of your community that's like what's worrying because it's
like oh you don't you when you see them you're like who is
that you're like oh it's that person but they used to be
this other person why do they look different now like stuff
like that marketing wise marketing wise and like uh uh
branding wise keeping the same one i mean if you swap
outfits that's fine but i meant like a full revamp is like
that's why like companies keep the same brand because
consistency always is good because if you have some you see
that thing and you're like oh i recognize them is this
person um so so that's why like a lot of that's why like in
companies people keep the same brand um and i would think
like if you want to keep the same brand for your future you
stay the same brand like i know like maybe you're like oh
but i want to be this next but like to if you want to play
it very safe um if you want to keep it very safe And you
don't want to take risk.
This is like the best way to do it.
Like this is the best way.
Like if you don't want to take any risk.
And like you don't know if the viewership will stay the
same.
Like type deal.
Management and organization.
All right.
Don't just hire anybody to be a manager.
It's so fucking stressful if you have the bad manager.
If you have like not a great manager.
somebody do not hire close friends never mix business and
relationships together it's never good I I would highly
highly suggest you do not hire close friends or any friend
like like oh my god do not hire close friends okay guys
don't mix it's always a rule to never mix business with
relations it's not great if you have the opportunity to hire
a manager just don't do that hire somebody look into someone
with actual business experience this is when you're getting
bigger as an indie obviously when you start out you don't
have managers you do this all yourself and so you have to if
you're starting out be sure to know how to
you're negotiating and don't let people like say like like
if you don't get like scammed into like signing a very
predatory contract when it comes to like sponsors and deals
because there's a lot of them out there so like you know you
want to do like a brand deal or a sponsor you have to be
sure you sign something that you really want to do and you
don't get like sucked into a
in terms of like like sponsors or merch and stuff like that
and that's like as an indie as an indie you there's like a
lot of those as an indie so like you have to be able to be
able to read these types of contracts if you don't have a
manager because but that is why you also get a manager to
avoid these things a lot of emails that come to me regarding
like opportunities and stuff my
sure that like before they before they the emails get to me
it gets like pre-reg by my management team so like i don't
have to deal with the bad ones so i can just say yes or no
on the good ones already that i get like um but yes get a
business lawyer if you want to be more serious get a
business lawyer yeah they get screened the emails get
screened so i'm sure that like i will not be that are like
predatory um but yeah anyway but yes get a business lawyer
to look through the contract to make sure everything is okay
um have a business email and put it on your twitter bio and
stream streamer platform don't think it's just gonna walk to
you have a business email out there very direct it's there
so you can get the emails instantly so like and also um make
sure the business email is like a little bit professional
yeah just a little bit professional i mean mine's doki can
read but it's also yeah that's stuff but also like um have a
pitch deck made i think it's a very good investment if you
want to chase sponsors if you want to like have sponsors
like um if you want to like approach sponsors and brand
deals have your own like portfolio and pitch deck made so
like when you send it to them like they can just see your
analytics and everything so like just make sure you have
those together also i saw like some people asking me like oh
what about like projects when you're organizing your project
and stuff like that like i talked about this earlier but
like um there's not really a host way.
I really do it.
That's like special.
At best, I have a lot of multiple projects going on and
stuff.
So I, because I have the opportunity to host and produce a
lot of projects, I, um, I am able to, uh, delegate a project
leader that runs the project.
mostly like the project leader will talk to me about what's
going on and then I also look into the server to see like
what's going on as well I look into the server and be like
okay seems like everything is going well but then the
project leader will be responsible with making sure
everything goes on track everything is on track and
everything is like going well they obviously get paid more
because they're the project leader also like the way is I
give updates.
I give server updates and be like, oh, here's the news.
What's going to happen?
And like, here are the new requirements.
Here's what I need.
Like, I would give updates.
But the project leader makes sure everything goes well and
keeps on track.
Also, please don't rely on Twitter DMs or Discord DMs.
Make a Discord server if you're doing a project.
You have to have, make sure everything, because like, oh my
God, it's so confusing when you have so many DMs everywhere.
Have a Discord server.
So you can keep track of everything.
I will show you an example of my Discord servers.
Bam!
Here you go.
This is how my Discord server goes.
On the left is me and my management team.
On the right is my editing team.
And animators.
I also have animators too.
So this is how I organize my Discord server.
This is how the Discord server is done.
So you see, like, here are all the important things that I
have.
and then on the right you can see like oh hey for editing
here are the rules here's my editing rules what I want the
clips to have um the general stuff for people want to talk
in general assets that I give them regarding like PNGs stuff
like that time stamp claims so the editors won't fucking
like overlap each other with time stamps like if they're
clipping something for clip downloads so like when they're
finished with a clip they just plop the links there They
just plop the links there for me to download.
And then if they have any editing thing they need to ask,
they just put it there.
And then I have private channels with each individual
editor.
So if they want to ask me anything privately, that's not
within like other, if other people, they don't want other
people to see, they talk to me in the private chat.
Everything is in, like, is organized in a way so that, um,
organized in a way so that like uh uh in the like it's just
automated type deal it's just very organized and like i know
where things are and and that's how i organize my stuff
because i just need to be sure that everything is in a way
so i can easily like look at it so like especially like
payment i tell them to tell me about payment in our private
channels instead their discord messages like instead of
discord dms because i can there's so many people i'm
managing or like working with that like i would get so many
dms like discord dms and i have to talk like socialize with
other people as well in discord dms so because of that i do
everything on servers if it's a project or if it's like um
if something's going on i do everything in the server so i
can i don't have to like discord search bar is so hard like
it is it's just better this way
shout out to like my management team to helping with the
organization of the server itself because like um it was not
this neat before I gave like a general template on how I
want the server to be like and then they made it more
organized so this is the left side is where me and my
management team live the right side is the editing team um
editing and animators the i combine the doki bites animators
into the same um into the same discord server so like uh so
like i don't have to like worry about uh about like more
than one so like also the editors and the animators don't
overlap each other in terms of clip moments Because I have a
rule, and I said that, I told them, for the animators and
editing team, I do not want repeats.
I don't want repeats.
So, like, the animator and the editor teams have to be sure
they don't animate or clip the same thing.
And that's why I combined them together.
So, yeah.
So that is how, like, everything is done.
The reason we're not using Slack is because we can't be
bothered.
That is why me and my manager team are not using Slack.
We can't be bothered.
So we're using Discord.
Alright.
General tips I've tried to follow.
These are my own way of streaming.
This is how I go about in terms of my own way of streaming.
First off, I saw like people were saying like, Oh, how do
you, like, deal with...
How do you deal with, like, losing topics and stuff?
Like, like, topics and stuff, like, dead air.
I actually keep a list of topics I want to talk about on
stream.
Every time I think of something I want to talk about, like,
if I have dead air?
If I think I have dead, I'm going to have dead air.
type random topics throughout the day and then i would just
pull that up if i have to i don't use it all the time i
don't use it all the time it's if i think i have dead air if
i don't know what i'm going to talk about i would just pull
it up and be like oh yeah i'll be like oh my god guys i just
remembered did you guys know blah blah blah blah like that's
really it but i don't do that all the time i don't do that
all the time i do it like maybe like once every two to three
weeks because i'm like back then when i was first starting
out i when i first starting out and i was not very good at
tangents and like in terms of like i don't know what to talk
about and i would make sure i write stuff down so i would i
would write bullet points so i would write bear hibernation
stuff like that just to make sure i remember so like i would
just write one bullet point and then i'll be like i remember
exactly the topic i'll be like oh yeah you know stuff like
that um but it's basically and like are not very good at
talking and it's because i'm so used to talking now that
like um i don't really use it anymore but i still put it i
write it down out of habit habit habit if you are a variety
streamer this is what i do this is my own personal opinion i
tend to keep long playthroughs three to four streams max
because the longer the series the less viewership is going
to get which is because our attention is really fucked now
this is where you're a YouTuber if you're a Twitch streamer
it's different if you're a Twitch streamer it's like really
different because like you know like I said before like
people don't know when you're going to stream whatever so
they always show up and they'll be like oh where are we
going to get today but if you're a YouTube streamer I
usually keep it three to four streams Just because like I
know by time it hits the fourth stream Like the viewership
will decline even harder It's just gonna go lower and lower
and lower So like that is why I try to keep it three to four
streams Um so it's just so it's just to keep the attention
span like Like still like there regarding it This is what I
do like I said personal experience you want to work with
artists that are not english-speaking get a translator i've
had this experience before i wanted to work with an artist
that didn't speak english and i wrote in english but i also
wrote my translated like my translation as well but then
they were like oh sorry we don't want to we only work with
people who speak it native like fluently because they didn't
want to deal with like issues if you didn't like the art and
then like they don't understand what you want changed and
stuff and the chat there's like translation issues and stuff
like that deep l is your friend if you want to how you
actually use a translator but i would highly suggest talking
with a translator getting an actual translator that's fluent
in the language or or use deep L but let the artist know
that you're using a translation software because you don't
want to like you know lie and be like I'm actually fluent or
you're using a translation like tool
but yes I highly suggest getting a translator to help you it
is much better in the long run and it's a lot more
convenient for you to get what you want.
Have a consistent time block.
People love consistency.
People love you being consistent.
That is why I have two set time blocks.
1230 p.m.
PST and 5 p.m.
PST.
That is my time block.
And that's what people know.
People know that you stream around those time.
Consistency is key.
always have a dedicated time block for whatever you stream
don't stream random hours all the time because you don't
your audience will not know what to do they'll be like what
the fuck what time do i show up i don't know they're always
different get a consistent time block even on twitch you
still the thing about twitch is that even they don't have a
set a set plan they are consistent with what time they
stream at so like always be consistent it's always the key
have mods don't self moderate it's not great and have them
be like mostly silent but like not too sad like it's like if
they want to interject they can but like the thing is we
don't want a mod to spam the chat just be like The thing is,
my mods, I have three mods working in this chat.
And like, they all have second accounts.
Their mod account is actually their second account.
So like, their mod, the real mods, the real, their real
accounts is among you.
It could be any of you guys.
So they don't have to, they don't, like, have to worry.
They don't, they can, like, actually talk to you guys.
It could be any of you guys.
So they have two accounts, one for moderating and one to
chat, like, be just like a regular dragoon.
I'm the mod smile.
Message receipt.
Have all your mods be...
silently i'm thinking of the super chat thank you thank you
but yes i have them mostly silent because i don't want to
cause any issues and that is why they're mostly silent um uh
also please make a business paypal and set up a business
account long run if you want to make this a long-term career
it would be so good for you just remember that please
remember to set everything up as a business because this is
your career now if this is what you want to do as a career
so uh so yeah anyway that's like basically one of my general
tips to follow when you want to if you want to like you want
to see what's going on behind my fucking brain all right
merch
say merch I did not realize how much merch matters until
recently and like for an indie and it's like a lot of income
can come from merch and um and basically I if you want to do
your own merch if you want to handle the whole merch
yourself and not want to look at distributors Alibaba is
your friend Alibaba is a great website to look for
manufacturers it is a good manufacturer website the thing is
when you're looking and when you're researching
manufacturers yourself you have to research the samples and
you have to look at like samples and like uh uh what else is
there and uh fuck okay I don't remember okay and you have to
like get like samples made and all that stuff too um there's
other manufacturer websites to look at there's a lot of them
and there's like ones in like America and stuff like that
ones in like Canada some in Japan and stuff like that a lot
of them are like on websites uh similar to like uh uh
different type there's like lots of websites for this too um
and the thing is um it's really hard to find a manufacturer
that you want to work with because you have to look at
sample size you have to look at samples and like make sure
you're not getting scammed of course not getting scammed and
the quality is what you want obviously the more you pay for
a manufacturer the more expensive the more expensive things
are going to get to be made and the more expensive things
are going to get to be sold but the quality is a lot better
so you have to be able to pick and choose you have to be
able to make sure that is what you want to work with anyway
making your own merch I was very luckily, I was a artist
alley.
I did artist alley a lot.
And I sold art at conventions.
So there's a lot of things you can do to make your own
merch.
Yay!
Like, these are things you can do yourself.
You don't have to get a manufacturer.
You can just do this yourself as a smaller indie.
You can just do this yourself as a smaller indie and still
have merch for your fans.
Button makers, they are $150 to $300 US dollars, including
the materials.
So like, it's just a button press.
You boom, boom, boom, bam.
You print out the artwork you want to make into a button,
and then you commission an artist to make a button design,
and then you print it out.
That's it.
And then you fucking boom, boom, boom, bam.
Done.
And that's how you make a button.
You install them for like two to three two to four dollars
depending on how big the button is and then gradually you
can make the investment back printing your own stickers
sticker paper that's a thing sticker papers are a thing or
you can fucking there's like local printing shops that make
stickers that you can just like you know order online or
order like from a shop from mom-and-pop shop or like i don't
know walmart
i used to cut my own stickers when i first started out in
artist alley and i still made money from that and they're
good and they're they make money and then printing your own
poster cards and prints at a local store that works you
don't have to worry it's like that you can do that as your
own merch Anyway, if you're going to work with distributors,
obviously they're going to take a cut of your money because
you're working with them.
They're going to be like doing the whole thing for you, like
the researching manufacturers, you know, researching
manufacturers and making sure like the quality and stuff
like that.
But you got to research and read the contract very
thoroughly.
I would highly suggest not going with one that's a startup
because for distributors and ones that have experience
distributing stuff because it's out of your hands because
you're not part of the process and honestly it's better to
work with somebody that has experience distributing stuff
because shipping things is a lot of work it's like I've done
shipping I ship stuff myself And, like, it's a lot of work.
And, like, it's not that easy.
I run my own.
I run my own thing all by myself.
It doesn't mean I'm going to do that forever, though.
It doesn't mean.
And I'm not, and I'm, like, very open to, like, maybe if I
find a distributor, I'd like, I can give them a percentage
cut.
I do it myself because I want to keep majority of the
earnings.
Because I know how to do it.
and I have experience doing it and that is why I handle I
handle like everything myself regarding merch and I know
other VTubers that do it as well not just me because I've
talked to I recently was talking to somebody regarding merch
stuff because we were like exchanging our company our like
manufacturers we were exchanging like info with each other
and stuff regarding like manufacturers and like oh like
What's the word?
Oh, fuck.
Just being like, oh yeah, like you do, you produce that.
I produce this.
Well, I want to try producing this later, too.
So then we were exchanging information with each other so we
can build up our knowledge and stuff.
So that's like, that's a good thing.
If you have like friends with somebody that also makes
merch, talk to them about it and like, like exchange
information with each other.
information I like be like oh yeah I'm planning on doing
this like oh where are you gonna be doing and stuff like
that and be like oh yeah I'm more look for a manufacturer
that does this as well and stuff like that um so that's what
um that's what I try to do I realize I realize I forgot a
slide so uh let me download this slide they're all PNGs and
so let me I realize I forgot um a slide real quick because
that sort of fits the topic that I want to talk about let me
add this in but this one is about networking and
collaboration because like the other stuff will not be as a
knowledge I wouldn't make sense if I go down there so let me
add that slide real quick add files where did I download it
okay let's see I think it's I think it's this is this collab
and networking I think this is all right all right let me
Let me push this lad up higher.
All right, networking and collabs.
There we go.
Balance your schedule.
I talked about this before.
But please, do not make it mostly collabs.
It should be, collab streams should not be more than solo
streams.
Because if you spend too many collabs per week, especially
when you're just starting out, then you're not building a
fan base and community that's and the community that's there
for you you want to have viewers that want to watch you so
you don't want to just have mostly collabs because people
would be like oh I want to watch them interact with this
streamer instead instead of actually like watching for you
so you have to have a healthy balance I do one to two
collabs per week Because if I have lots of collabs going on,
I also try to balance it more with solo streams.
Because I know my dragoons, they also want some personal
dragoon time.
They want me to interact with the chat.
And that's why, like, they want to have an identity.
You don't want to be the collaborer.
Like, you don't want that to be your identity.
You just collab.
You don't have solo content.
You want to have personal content so people will know your
personality.
don't rely too much on collabs.
Like I said, if you're relying too much on collabs, you're
basically like giving yourself a crutch and you have a
harder time developing your personality and presence.
It also has if you're on YouTube, it like gives more
opportunities for like dead subs and followers and stuff and
you don't want that.
You don't want people to just follow you because you collab
with this one person.
You want them to follow you because they enjoyed that
experience and they want to watch more of you.
This is why a lot of like collab channels die so fast
there's a okay you can look at this example with flesh
tubers a lot of flesh tubers they like uh become big because
of the group they are with because they have like a youtube
group but as soon as that youtube group falls apart their
channel dies because the viewers they only want to watch
that stream that channel for the group they are in not
because of the people they are.
They're like, oh, my friend group experience.
No, like, that shit sucks.
Because they're like, no, I watched you because I wanted to
have the friend group experience so I can live vicariously
through this friend group.
And then now that you don't have that friend group, it's not
as fun.
I used to watch the creatures.
I live vicariously through the creatures.
and like that's the thing especially like when they started
going their separate ways they didn't have really an
identity beyond that they didn't have the identity like it
was just like it was literally like the friend group was
gone but you know there's like so many experience you can
fucking look at Minecraft and like uh what's the quibble
quap or whatever
like shit like that like you can't be just the friend group
you have to be your own individual um all right how to be
good at collapse this is my my opinion but there's two roles
in a collab this is how i see it the support and the leader
so the support is obviously like you look at it as a comedy
duo but it can be like a group thing too so so you can have
the straight man and the leader or like the the dumb one or
the chaotic one or the one with the comedy you need someone
to react and the other one to be there someone to bring
their reaction and stuff um and so or you can be skills you
can have is to be both of them and i think i personally i
can be both i can be a reactor if i'm in a group that's way
too chaotic i can be the straight man if i need it to be i
can be the reactor like the one that tries to be like the
sane one in the group like it is possible if you can have
the skill set to be both you are you can be a really good
content creator because you're not locked into you're not
locked into a group in a way you're not locked into certain
people you can collab with and that is what makes a very
strong collab so you don't want a whole group filled with
supporters like you know all the people who can only do
support you don't want a full group of chaotic people
because it will be way too much able to have a healthy
balance.
This is what I look into when collabs.
I try to find a healthy balance of people that would
balance, that would like that would be good foils to each
other.
Sometimes I look at, I try to min-max collab groups in the
past.
I have done that.
Sometimes they're random.
It depends on what kind of collab I'm planning.
I have min-max collabs before in the past and I have like
done random people.
It really really depends on like how you want this
collaboration to be like because I can I the thing is I have
the um I have the I guess like the opportunity to be able to
do random because I can do both roles I can be a support and
a leader I can be like I can do both like the uh uh why I
can do both like oh the chaotic role the the save random
shit role or can be there to react and stuff and to be able
to like uh to be able to like you know make it so like you
know i'm i'm enabling whoever is the leader i'm making sure
i'm enabling the leader and i'm enabling their content to be
bigger than what it was like they would say something and i
would make it make it like more funny and i'll make it more
like oh chaotic or something like stuff like that and uh
that is like what makes a good collab and that's how you
organize when i'm at min maxing i make sure i choose like
there's some collabs i would purposely pick regarding like
collab partners because i know the collab group that comes
out of it will be really good content because i know the
people in that group like will reflect really will like foil
each other really well like they'll other really well and
i've done that before i've also done random people like
being who's free like i've done both it really depends on
like um it really depends on like how you want to see the
collab um anyway uh so that is like my my like ideology when
it comes to setting up these collabs uh socialize i hate it
but Always remember the people who were there for you.
So, return favors and offer opportunities back to other
people who were there for you or who have done the same to
you.
Like, I've done this before.
If I have an extra invite to something, I would give this
invite to somebody that I knew was there for me.
Or, like, that I knew that I knew would benefit from.
Like, I would be like, oh, hey, you were there for me.
I have an invite to this thing.
Do you want to do it?
Because I know they're there for me.
I know that if something happens, if something comes up,
they'll have something to return back.
They'll be like, oh, hey, like, this person was there for
me, so I'll be there for you.
Like, just make sure you always remember the people who,
like, returned favors or did you a favor.
You always remember that.
And it's like paying it forward.
So it's always good for you long run to be able to, like,
remember these things.
and uh the worst people can say is no like i said or should
you shot the worst is they ghost you or they say no you have
to get used to rejection it's happened a lot i've ghosted
people a lot because i get overwhelmed sometimes people
ghost you not because they didn't want they didn't want to
work with you it's because they're so fucking busy and that
has happened to me i've ghosted people because i was so
fucking busy and i was so very overwhelmed i've been
overwhelmed And so, like, it's very common for me to be
super overwhelmed and not, like, reply back instantly.
I've had moments where I'd be like, I'm so sorry for taking
a month to reply.
Everything was so overwhelming.
I'm sorry.
And then, um, it's understandable.
So, like, just be aware that these things happen.
And a lot of content creators, like, have their own lives.
And, like, maybe they don't want to collab.
And then they just don't want to say no.
Gotta live with it.
If you're in content creation, you gotta live with these
things.
like you gotta like you just gotta deal with it you want
this to be your job this is really it okay what else what
else oh yeah websites and resources all right so here are
some really good websites and resources for you to use for
streaming there's booth there's nizima i don't know if i'm
pronouncing right i'm so sorry uh i don't even think i
should pronounce it because The four things I listed,
they're really good resource websites.
Both.
The first two, they're really good for assets and
backgrounds and like VTuber models or skin suits.
All of that.
The last two are really good for like also for assets and
backgrounds and like copyright free shit.
Like they're, those are really good.
Like I would highly suggest looking at these websites for
like just information you need, and stuff like that or like
assets you don't want to pay a lot of the things on there
are free that's the best part a lot of there is for free
care fun is really good for karaoke's or singing like you
don't you're worried about like copyright claims and stuff
like that i highly suggest using care fun because like they
have like usually if you use care fun stuff you don't have
to worry about copyright things um because like they're all
like it's it's a there's a subscription fee though it's like
50 i think a month but if you're uh if you're like a regular
singer or like you like to do karaoke's this is a good
investment for the future and then schust schust schust i
don't know they're they're like really good like um you have
to do a patreon pledge stuff and but they're really good for
like uh like you know like those like really uh pretty uh
immersive like settings and stuff where like the light at
the background actually looks like it connects with the with
the vtuber that's it that's the thing it's just really good
atmospheric stuff to use when you're streaming so that's
what they use so these are really all really good websites
and resources um if you really want to look for free things
you don't want to spend money i highly this glass is free I
literally look for VTuber glasses asset Free If you really
want to find free stuff These are really good places To like
look at If you want free things Okay mental health care I
will admit I am not the person to go to advice for this
Because I still battle with it frequently If you want to be
a content creator creator or a V-Tuber, you have to know,
you're so fucked when it comes to mental.
There's no one that's okay.
You have to be aware that you're gonna go through some
mental health shit.
It could be like...
little bit doesn't have to be like um it doesn't have to be
like really bad but you will you will feel you will feel it
if you want to be a content creator or like anything to do
with making content on the internet you will not have like
the most positive mental health experience it's all about
mitigating it like it's like just make sure you have a
support system that is outside of content creation.
Because if you have like a support system that's within
content creation, you're just in a fucking echo chamber of
like some things.
So you'll need like an outside perspective.
You really need very thick skin to be able to like do this
as a career.
Like especially like you're going to deal with so many
things.
Like you're going to deal with a lot of stuff.
So you really need thick skin.
And even if you have thick skin you're still gonna go
through some mental health shit um and on the internet
because your numbers will affect you you can say numbers
don't affect numbers will affect you because you don't want
to fail like you know you of course you'll be like i'm
trying to have better numbers because i want to have a
successful career like you don't you still have to pay
attention to it so it's still gonna affect you so um you
just have to be able to have a good support system outside
of just content stuff outside every once in a while like so
just be able to like handle that like you have the risk for
being a fucking content creator is that it's not a very
mentally healthy thing
being an entertainer is not just like on the internet you
can look at like Hollywood actors those people are not okay
Hollywood actors, TV actors, celebrities outside of fucking
the internet, they are not okay as well.
If you're in the entertainment business, like you're,
you're, you're, you're, you're going to have to go through
some shit.
So you have to be aware and that is like the biggest risk
you have to take.
all right anyway i'm gonna look at questions on twitter now
to see if there's anything that i can i'm gonna look at any
of the questions i have on twitter there's anything i want
to answer but that is basically uh that is basically like
all i have written down for myself to talk to you guys about
so i hope like all the stuff i have um all the stuff i have
also i'll do like i'll put like questions from chat as well
um all the stuff i have written out i hope the slides itself
has been very informative chat i hope they have been very
informative and that it has like helped you guys figure out
like give you advice and tips on how to go through like
content creation I will be taking questions now from I'll be
looking at the Twitter thread that I made regarding if
anybody had questions before I made the stream as well as
taking questions from chat I hope it assists you regarding
if you want a vtuber career in content creation and how to
game the algorithm um okay so I have this one question that
I saw and one of them was like how do you manage your
battery when it comes to networking, creating video content,
streaming with your VTuber skin suit, and responding to a
bunch of brand deals or collabs.
How do you keep the momentum going during all that work?
Well, all my energy is mostly on streaming.
That's why when I say off stream, I'm like really different
is because I've more or more of my energy within streaming
and like uh and then i go to power save mode the moment
after streaming is also like sort of an escape for me it's
not very healthy but like for me i uh i like to stream
because it is like i very much enjoy streaming and it is
like my way of escaping work because my work is off stream
it is my my my work is off stream at the moment so so that
is why i love streaming this is how i keep my energy all my
energy is streaming and um i do power save after streaming i
have a management team that helps me with brand deals at
best like i would look through the details of stuff that got
screened and filter out and then uh and then when it comes
to networking i take that really slow at the moment.
Networking is the thing I'm like really slow on because
right now I am focused on stabilizing myself.
Um I am trying to make sure I'm more stabilized in my career
because like I said like my career just started out of a
sudden as an indie and I'm still at the point where I'm
still trying to stabilize.
There's a lot of groundwork that we have to make and we're
still making that groundwork and there's a lot of things I
haven't announced i haven't announced yet regarding like uh
like you know future sponsors future brand deals there's so
many things i haven't yet been able to announce uh because
we're still like it's like stabilizing we're still
establishing things um but we're slowly getting there so
that is really how how my life is at right now um all right
uh neil thank you for super chat thank you thank you do you
have workout routine or do you sustain through pure mental
fortitude and caffeine that's the thing um late right now um
right now i haven't really had a really decent workout
routine at the moment um because i'm not stabilized at the
moment before in the past i did i have a treadmill in my
room but because like you have to take some cuts in terms of
like your routine and that is sadly one the things I had to
take a cut on.
I don't normally drink caffeine, but I have drank caffeine
at least like once or twice a week.
I have drank some caffeine once or twice a week.
And, um, and because I really need it.
Like I, there's been a lot of stuff, um, that I have to do.
And I, sometimes I get really tired after a while.
And, um, I have, unfortunately that is like one of the
things i have to do i have to take caffeine now because it's
been like real a lot of work to stay like uh stay up i only
drink caffeine off stream i don't do it on stream i know a
lot of people think i'm like super energetic or like um i
take something when i'm streaming i do not drink any type of
caffeine i drink water i just drink water when i'm streaming
off stream i actually drink like tea or uh coffee just to be
like uh just to like survive if i have a stream at like
really late i would drink coffee i would drink coffee if i
have a stream really fucking late because like you know i'm
fucking exhausted it was like three in the morning so of
course i'm gonna drink coffee to just survive
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What should I do with my favorite VTubers suddenly last a
lot out of nowhere?
Is that the side?
No comment.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Malcolm, how do you find game?
What games are popular?
Are there any tools do you use for this?
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Very easy.
You go on Steam.
You go to recently released or upcoming games.
Recently released on Steam.
You look at the reviews.
If a new game gets like more than 700 plus reviews, this is
how I found Pineapple on Pizza, by the way.
I was like the first one to stream Pineapple on Pizza
because I literally looked at the reviews and I was like,
this game came out yesterday.
Like, I'll be like, this game came out yesterday.
It has a thousand reviews.
What the fuck?
And then I streamed it.
And that's how I found out.
I was one of the first one to stream it I saw like there
were a thousand reviews with a game that just came out
yesterday and then I just streamed it because I was like
clearly this is gonna be a meta game clearly this game is
gonna be popular um and it was like basically like you just
like look at steam reviews if it's like if there's like I
said if uh if a game on steam recently released has more
than like 500 plus reviews then most likely it is going to
be like a meta game it's going to be a meta stream you can
also look at upcoming releases and just judge by the
upcoming releases another way is to i said this before but
you look at twitch and see what's the most like you go at
twitch and see like what's popular you go to browse and then
categories And then, bam, you can see, like, if you see a
stream of a game that's like, oh, I've never seen this
before.
I've never seen this game before.
What the fuck?
And then you click on it and you're like, oh, that's a new
stream meta.
The Twitch front page is basically a story of, like, what's
meta.
You can also follow some big content creators.
Like, uh, these content creators, they always follow meta,
which is, like, uh uh moist critical uh let's see moist
critical and follows twitch meta not twitch meta follows
streamer meta very well he follows streamer meta in terms of
games really really well and i i would like sometimes like i
think i saw i think i saw a supermarket simulator uh no not
from him i saw it somewhere else i don't remember who i
don't remember who i saw that was streaming super market
simulator and i i knew that like uh i knew like someone was
streaming it and i knew that was going to be that's the
stream meta and that's why i put it on my schedule because i
saw somebody stream it and i was like oh my god i'm going to
stream it because i was like wait this is the next stream
game um and that's why uh uh that's why i streamed it i
think i'm trying i think SureFore gets addicted to a new
game.
I knew it's a good game.
Ludwig is also a good stream meta follower.
Ludwig follows meta really well.
Let's see.
What else?
So, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You mentioned making merch is very important for income.
How much does it cost usually commission art for
merchandise?
Give me a super chat.
Thank you.
That really depends on what kind of merch you want to make.
Obviously, I gave some cheap options.
I would think acrylic stands and acrylic stands, pins,
stickers, prints.
They are the most convenient ones and the easiest to make
because you can't fuck it up.
You can't fuck up stickers.
You can't fuck up acrylic stands.
up like prints and stuff like that those are like the
easiest to make and like um you don't have to worry about
grabbing samples and stuff like that the more complicated
the merch the more oh and keychains yes and keychains the
more complicated the merch the harder is to grab like to
grab like merch that's not fucked up you know like you know
if a manufacturer sent you merch it's like you might get
more like uh duds than you do like uh actual like quality
quality that you can send out to people even enamel pins
enamel in animal pins oh my god you have to find a really
good manufacturer for pins like enamel pins because like you
can fuck that up so easily i've had one time where i got a
manufacturer that like sent me like the quality control for
that is so hard to manage because they would send me like uh
i don't i never worked with that one again but they sent
thousand pins or something and like, I think like 200 of
them were like duds.
Like there was like markings on it that I had to clean
myself and like at the, but even then I didn't, I couldn't
get like the scratch marks and stuff out of it.
There's like, and I had to like sell it as a bargain price
and stuff because it's like, it's so hard.
That's why it's like, and now pins are like some of the
riskiest for quality control.
Anything beyond like keychain, stickers, pin, like buttons,
acrylic stands are really hard to get quality control right
um so you guys gotta be like really careful for stuff like
that and regarding art like i said it depends on who you
want to commission depends on each artist has his own rate
so i can't give you an estimate there's some artists that
charges a lot there's some artists that don't it really
depends on the estimate uh some artists will charge a
commercial price some won't just have to it's basically who
you oh many thank you the super chat thank you thank you
what's the best way to announce a big project event so that
you can receive the most engagement on stream live that's
really the best way if you're a streamer on stream live
announce it you don't say anything about what the thing is
you say special announcement special event uh and then you
reveal it on stream because and you reveal the participants
on stream you don't reveal it on twitter or like social
media first you reveal it want to know who's participating
so you announce it on stream one by one uh because it gets
bring it builds it builds up like um anticipation and stuff
um and you're like oh and you're like oh who's gonna be next
whoa um so announcing any you announce things live not via
um social media unless it's like a tournament invite then
like you can't really announce that live
yeah you it's like you see like everybody always does this
oh i'm doing this thing wait until the very end you wait
like oh if you want to hear what the announcement is you
wait until the very end because you make all the viewers
wait until the very end they show come to watch you do a
regular stream if it's a regular stream with announced
tacked on the end it make it makes the viewer stay until the
very end because they want to know what the announcement is
so um that's what like uh that what brings in um all the
engagements for your stream uh let's see uh let me see what
to uh what to do here okay uh direct thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you so you talk how do you go about
learning a language becoming some influence requires years
doesn't it you You're, okay, you want to learn languages.
Get a tutor.
Get a teacher.
The best, because the best way to learn a language is being
able to speak that language with somebody else.
And the easiest way to do that is having a tutor.
Having a teacher or a friend to help you with your studies.
Because if you just read and write, you're not learning as
fast as like speaking the language with somebody.
So you have to always be able to communicate.
You have to be able to communicate with somebody to be able
to build up your language learning.
And like, speaking the language helps you learn so much.
Like, you just have to get a tutor.
You can grab like so many resources.
Like, you know, I have like lots of books and everything.
And like just study the book.
But if you don't speak that language regularly, then it
won't help you.
is not a good enough way to learn language.
Duolingo is like substitute.
You can use it as an extra learning, but it's not the main
thing you use for learning.
You have to have other ways to learn.
You can't just rely on Duolingo.
Yeah, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Um...
Uh...
Singy, think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hearing everything you have to say made me realize that I'm
better at pursuing content creation as a hobby rather than a
job.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
The thing is, a lot of content creators start off as a
hobby, because it's not stable.
It's not a stable job, and it's all about luck.
But it's all about trying to maximize your luck as well.
I would say, oh yeah, someone says watch streams.
Yes, if you want to get better, watch streams in that
language you're trying to learn.
I improved a lot in my Cantonese and my Mandarin, because
when I lived in Asia, I would only watch the TV it was
playing, and then I would like, watch like shows like um
shows in that language uh because like you know the tv was
on i had nothing to do and i was i couldn't play on my pc so
i would just sit there and just watch and i got better i got
better in my listening skills i got better in my listening
skills and my speaking skills so i highly recommend watching
streams in that language and you're gonna slowly pick up the
language as well if you're learning already if you're
learning already it helps improve your uh it helps improve
it a lot uh but yes like i said content creation a lot of
people start out as a hobby if it's best if you start off
with having a as like a um as like an extra income and not
like you know go full in because like you know you always
you need a backup plan you always need to have a backup plan
you know so like a lot of people start off content creation
as a hobby and then later on when it gets more successful
you start investing more into it and then when you make
enough money you can like you know fully commit to it and
that's like the safest way I think if you want to go safe I
would say like always have a backup plan because you don't
quit your day job always like make sure you have something
in the backup just in case
let's see what else how much what do i have um let's see uh
volley think of a super chat thank you thank you i made a
plushie of my vtuber and my subs one to buy it 35 plus 122
for international shipping that is way too how big is the
plushie that is way too much for a plushie It also, where do
you live without doxing yourself?
Without doxing yourself, like, that is honestly way too much
for shipping.
It really depends on, like, how much the, uh, oh, okay, uh,
how much the, how big the plushie is, too.
Because at that point, that is way too expensive.
especially like if it's an NA and plushie should not be that
expensive for shipping I don't know overseas shipping I
don't know like how bad shipping is in other countries but
like I know for NA that's way too expensive for
international and um at that point it's just so much easier
to just find a distributor because distributors help if
you're if the plushie is like manufactured um you're not the
one that made that plushie then like at that point getting a
distributor helps with that but I feel like I feel like $122
in general is way too much for from what I'm seeing in my
experience I know like in different countries it really
depends on um on like how much shipping is in different
countries and that's why some countries some companies have
distributors um have distributors in like cheaper places
like not cheaper place in like in that place like the
distributor would be like you know they want to distribute
stuff in america but uh the company is in japan they will
buy a warehouse they would have a warehouse in stuff like
that just to help with shipping and stuff and that's why
people find distributors because to help with shipping um
let's see i'm trying to see what else to answer um
uh niana thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hi
doki my question is How to smoothly approach other streamers
to make genuine connections.
Twitter and their chat.
A lot of my friends I've made before I, you know, started
being a serious VTuber.
Like before the friends I made like two years.
Like friends I made before I started being serious VTubering
two years ago.
It was from Twitter and Twitch chat.
Like I was a Twitch streamer.
And I would like hang out.
I would raid them.
A lot of them are artists too.
A lot of the friends I've made, because I was an artist
YouTuber.
So I would draw a lot.
And I just do art streams and everything.
And because of that, I made friends by rating other Twitch
streamers.
And also talking to them on Twitter and interacting with
them.
And then they'll tweet something.
Like they'll tweet art.
I'm like, oh my God.
I love your art and stuff like that.
and I would like give them like signal boost them if they
want that they have that they tweet something I would like
boost booster tweets and stuff by retweeting it and like you
know talk to them on discord and talk to them on twitch and
like like play games with them on stream like it's all about
um just like being consistent and stuff like that obviously
I am a lot more busy now I'm not a lot more busy now so I
don't have that you know I don't have time to really like do
that anymore and uh and now i just like you know i uh uh it
is a whole harder for me to to make more friendships because
i have a lot of stuff going on and um i have to make sure i
can balance my schedule and stuff like that but back then uh
back then i would just you know just hang out and talk to
them and just raid raid their streams and because i wanted
to like know them
see big boy thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
hi dokey quick question is it possible for me to start
streaming as a hobby despite having yes you can have any
time block i used to be a dgen streamer i wouldn't start my
stream when i was a twitch streamer i would stream at 9 p.m
and i had a audience for 9 p.m streams sometimes i stream at
1 a.m and i had an audience for that a dgen hour streamer
like if people were up in dgen hours time or people on the
other side of the world wanted a english-speaking streamer
to watch i was there for them but yes it doesn't matter
anytime is possible you don't have to worry anytime is you
just stream don't like just stream if you have a a a really
bad work hour schedule um just make that your consistent
stream hours there's an audience base somewhere for it um
let's see uh so i think of the super chat thank you how do
you find collabs as a small streamer literally little
friends connection and networking thank you for super chat
thank you thank you there are i would find other people
around your your viewer viewer level and just interact with
them they want they want connections too as an indie that's
the biggest thing as an indie we all want to find a group
that's why i'm doing so many collabs because i'm trying to
find a consistent group to hang out with to like see which
who i groove with the most so i'm trying to collab with like
bunch of people from different areas to like meet new people
and like just want to have a consistent group of people to
just hit up to do games with and um just reach out like the
the biggest hurdle is just reaching out to people and i'm
pretty sure those people who are around your range they want
more friends too they want more connections they want to
find new vtubers new But never forget who was there for you.
Never forget.
There's a lot of people that I used to know that was like
around my view count when I was like a lot smaller.
And then they're now really big streamers.
You don't know.
Just never forget what they did for you and what you did for
them.
So you always just remember that like just who stuck out for
you and who like was there.
just remember that and just reach out to people around your
similar range because I'm pretty sure they're also looking
for friends they're also looking for people to play with
that's one of the hardest parts in indie people just and why
people want to join a community they want to have sorry why
people want to join a company they want to have a community
that they can just hit up on and bam easy they just want a
community like a group of people to just play and stream
um let's see thanks thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you how do you come up with good jokes on the spot and
chat entertain so is it why is it separate content like
music and game on different channels thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you um how do i come up with good jokes
on this spot and chat that's just a talent like i can't i
can't give advice on that naturally just had that as a skill
for me so like i'm sorry i i i unfortunately i can't give
you advice on how to come up with good jokes on the spot and
like chat entertain is just for chat entertainment don't
have don't bash something over and over again don't beat up
a dead horse that's really it like chat entertainment as
long as you don't beat a dead horse and like keep
Apparently, that's like the best advice I can give you like
there are moments where like some jokes would come up that I
would say that became like memes and like like phrases that
were like my chat would consistently bring up but I wouldn't
say it that often I would say it like I wouldn't or I would
never say it ever again.
I say this phrase once and then it's forever.
It's like the the chat loves it so much.
They always remember it.
But what they don't know was I said it once.
once on one stream and then but it was my identity
and and like the thing is you have to know when to forgive
the joke back or or like or when to like stop a joke because
you have to make it so that the chat doesn't get tired of it
um because you don't overkill it as long as the chat is
entertaining themselves that's all that matters and
regarding like how do i come up with these jokes on the spot
i think you guys should know when i first started streaming
i wasn't i got peer pressure to stream i like i didn't
stream because i wanted to be a streamer this is a little
lore i don't know if i told this before i'm pretty sure i
have basically i got discovered in overwatch and like
because um i was using uh voice chat to like play overwatch
and i had a streamer in my game and then um later on became
friends with some streamers who played overwatch uh like
they was all high ranked overwatch and um And then like they
told me to start streaming And so they were like Oh we think
you're very entertaining You should just because I would say
like random shit Like
These are like big overwatch content creators at that time
too And like I would say like something that would be funny
And then like they would be like wait you should like stream
You can be a really good You can be you're really
entertaining stream and you're entertaining on stream
because at that time i had more energy off stream to
actually be entertaining like just hanging out you know just
hanging out i had like like i can entertain people like as
just hanging out not because like also to be fair like even
then when i hang out with people i say some fucking shit
that would be like what the fuck
um um because of that like they were like you should start
streaming and then i did i started streaming uh because of
that um and that's why i i honestly can't give advice on
like how to do jokes and how to be entertaining because like
i said like the reason why i started streaming was because i
literally got peer pressure to by like my friends because
they were like oh my god you're pretty entertaining you
should try streaming i was like okay but i never committed
to it i never I just did it for fun like I never like
actually try tried and never like kept it consistent I had
like moments where I took like four plus months break
without telling anybody because I never like I didn't I
didn't have much I was barely an affiliate I was just like
fucking around and I was like I didn't feel like streaming
so now I'll just be like all right I'm not going to stream.
I didn't.
I was just like, all right.
I didn't take it seriously because I didn't see it as a
career.
I didn't see it as a...
And it would happen multiple times.
It wasn't like, oh, yeah, the first time there was four
months and I came back.
I would be like four months.
And then I streamed for like two to three weeks or something
or like an entire month.
And then I disappeared for another six months.
And then I was just like, whatever.
so i never took it seriously i just i just did it for fun um
that's really that's why i can't give like actual advice on
this because it's like i feel like i'm not like the right
person to uh to give advice on how to be entertaining
because i for me it was just naturally within me um yeah
you're lucky i'm not i don't do that anymore i actually this
is a job now we're so lucky that i actually see this as a
job now yeah the bark knights the og bark knights they are
the strongest knights out there they i there's like okay the
og discord is like still running like the og discord that i
i started off with that's been they these people those fans
they still exist and they're dragoons now but they've been
like supporting me even through all these hiatuses like it's
actually crazy oh my god but like but it's also like how i
um i forgot to give you guys this but like how to nurture a
community because what you give to the community is what
they give back to you so like that's why you have to love
and care your community because they do so much to support
you they like my my bark nights they've been there for me
for all my hiatuses but like i still try to like like let
them know i care like in a way so like um you have to be
able to nurture a really loving and loyal community and
first off you need a name your community you They need a
name
They need a unite under a name And that is what I did You
guys are dragoons We had bark nights before And stuff like
that And you need to be You need to be able to Do stuff Give
back to your community You have to be able to give back to
your community Every so often When I was a Twitch streamer I
would have, like, sketch raffles.
By the way, which reminds me, I need to fucking do the
sketches and stuff from the donations alert.
I'm sorry, I've been so busy.
But that's a...
When I was a Twitch streamer, I would have sketch raffles.
And then the top three...
And then, like, I would have, like, raffles where, like, all
my...
I would have, like, a lottery where, like, all my
subscribers were put in a lottery.
I would pick like five subscribers to win art from me.
And then my most gifted subscriber, I would send them a
postcard to be like, thank you for supporting me this month.
Like stuff like that.
I had made like little gift bundles and everything.
And I didn't even have like a large viewership.
I didn't have like a large viewership, but I had like a very
dedicated community because I really appreciated them.
I really appreciated what they did and like sort of
supporting me for this long.
like gift bundles and stuff where my top support is and
being like a personal post guide and be like oh thank you
for all the gifted subs i had guys i had at one point i have
i had 500 subs on twitch but my average viewership was 30 to
40.
like like because i was like i was i just like i was just
like uh I was just like I really cared about my community.
I really cared about them.
Because I really appreciated them.
And I really appreciated them.
And I tried very hard to show my appreciation.
And here, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
So like it's all about like being a really good content
curator.
Is making sure you give back to your community.
you show them that you really care and that you care because
you can't be a content creator without your viewers and you
have to show them that you appreciate it and that's why i
try really hard with doing all these projects doing all
these like fun things like events and like fun things with
you guys and like trying to do lots of like interactive
stuff with you guys is how i show i care and how i like um
and like all the things i uh because i couldn't be here
without you guys uh all right let's see uh what else what
else can i what else uh i holy shit i almost
that's whoa i did not realize how long i've been streaming
for thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh yeah
start small and care about those around you glad to hear
these tips don't you i'm doing fine too but i cannot draw
nor draw nor do more than playing games and talking with
them.
What can I do?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's sometimes what they need.
The chat just wants your entertainment and your company.
You don't have to do more than like, uh, what they're happy
with.
Like, by the time you have a bigger viewer base, you can
start reinvesting more into your channel.
Like, when I first started, all I did was just play video
games.
And then I, the bigger I got, the more I reinvested.
Sometimes, like I said, you start small and then the bigger
you get, the more money you have earned, reinvest in your
channel or save money.
Honestly, there's a lot of people who do YouTubing different
ways.
They want to use YouTubing to be able to afford a house in
the future or like an apartment.
I put it in, I reinvest in my content because like I enjoy
making content and I enjoy reinvesting I'm playing more so
of the long game because I can save for a house for like an
actual place to live later on down the line for me this is
me don't follow this if you don't have a stable enough like
career but for me content creation for me obviously would
never be long term because content creation never has a long
lifespan within the internet unless you're the 0.001 so for
me i try to take advantage of what i can do as a content
creator and what i can invest in as a content creator uh
this is not financial advice this is not financial advice
but i put my money investing in my channel because i know
this is not for too long in terms of like my future and like
i want to be able to experience this as much as I can before
I, you know, can't do the internet stuff anymore.
So, obviously, I want to be able to reinvest all this to
experience all the things I never got, I would never be able
to experience if it was like 20 or 30 years in the line I'd
never be able to experience this.
So I want to reinvest this in my channel to be able to do
all these things that I've never got to do before.
And, because like, I have a friend that keeps fucking
bugging me to fucking buy a house.
one of my friends was like please use that money to buy a
house and i'm like no no i'm gonna pay an animator to make
another toky bites animation
so um so that's my opinion i i know i should I know I should
buy something instead of renting
Okay Okay Alian thank you for the super chat Thank you think
Which part of content creation do you struggle with How do
you get past those roadblocks Interact socialize with people
outside of just streaming I'm so bad at that I'm really bad
on like Twitter socialization And just socializing with
people I like talking to people Like
what did I say I like talking to people like in a call but I
hate talking to people on messaging stuff I don't know like
I rather like I think this is why like whenever I get a call
with somebody having like message in a while we would talk
for hours we would talk for like four plus hours I remember
like I haven't talked to this one person in a while and then
like when we got in a call we would just like play a video
game and just talk for like four plus hours and then we're
like oh fuck wait we broke busy tomorrow we should go to
sleep we it'll be like four or five a.m or something it'll
be like five a.m and we're like oh shit oh my god wait oh
fuck okay we we should sleep because we both have a busy
workday like stuff like that like i i don't like just
messaging i like to be in a call with somebody because
that's majority of how i like to interact with people um i'm
just not like a person that like socialize via message and
that's like one of the hardest part because that's how you
network a lot of networking is done via socializing on
messages but i've done more network i i personally feel like
i've made more progress networking just talking to people on
like on the call like
bob thank you for the super chat thank you thank you please
buy a house here house fun thank you next thing thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you uh it would make me
very happy to see your more financially secure long term
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all right
guys i'm gonna answer uh two more questions and then i'm
gonna call it here chat i'm gonna i'm gonna call it here uh
i'll answer Two more questions for you guys.
If you guys have any.
Cool.
Questions I haven't answered before.
Let's see.
Let me see real quick if there's anything.
Also, if you're a content creator, I know like it's a lot of
people are like, ew.
But like if you're a content creator, get Twitter blue.
It's...
You have to.
I know it sucks, but, like, as a content creator, you have
to.
It's actually, like, really good.
Uh, because, like, first off, the, what was it, editing your
post and being able to tweet really long tweets?
is really good.
It's just, it sucks that that is like a bot service, but
like it's being able to make long tweets and being able to
post longer videos as well as editing your tweets is just a
really, really helpful thing to have.
And I know it sucks, but like it's a good investment in the
long run as a content creator, as a content creator.
Um, great.
Thank you for the super chat.
you uh and this will be my last question that i'll answer
thank you so much for the stream it's been incredibly
educational how do you balance doing things out of passion
versus because they're what's good for your growth um you
have to sacrifice things to grow like you have to be able to
uh be able to sacrifice of course you still sprinkle there's
a seven days in a week right you do something you're
passionate about in like half the week and it's something
you know it's what i do i have a fomo game like once a week
at least or at most once a week there is a fomo game in the
schedule like climbing or something or like supermarket
simulator because that is the game of the week um it's fun
it's fun but like obviously like how some of them is like
purposely games you know like the fucking climbing game it's
fun for the viewers and it's fun to watch this streamer
suffer so it's like you know sacrifices have to be made it's
more so of like you have seven days of a week you didn't
obviously balance the stuff you're passionate about versus
the stuff that you want to grow with and you have to be able
to sacrifice that to grow in whatever what you want and uh
and that's like the risk you have to take there's so many
risks you have to take in content creation streaming is a
risk and you have to be ready to take these risks uh but yes
that would be my last question of the day I hope this stream
was informative um and that you were able to learn a little
bit and that other vtubers are able to you know figure out
what they want with what they want with what they want to
stream and stuff like that i hope this might be like my only
time i actually was talking death about all of this so uh i
hope it was still important there's obviously a lot of
things i could have said there's obviously a lot more things
i could give insight on um but i hope that what i gave you
guys was enough to help you in some way and i a lot about
content creation.
Anything I want to say is that you always want to keep eyes
on you.
The reason why I was able to grow fast and big, before you
know, as Doki, was because I did things that I was super
passionate about and I love streaming and I loved being
involved in the community and I love being involved outside
of just VTubing.
I try to network outside beyond V-tubing And that's And I
try to do a lot of things I want to be involved in as many
things as possible And that is like one of the biggest
things We're growing Is that you want to be You want to be
like everywhere type deal You want to be like everywhere So
people will know, recognize you And I also organized a lot
of events and projects That kept the momentum going and
stuff.
I was willing to reinvest in my channel.
If you're willing to reinvest in your channel and know what
your strongest suit are, that is the best way to grow, in my
opinion.
And I knew how the algorithm worked.
I knew what would grow a channel.
And I knew what would benefit the algorithm.
The moment you realize what makes the algorithm works Is
when you realize how you can get bigger as a If you hit that
boost, the initial boost That's when you know what can keep
you going Um Um, but yeah Think long term It's not about
short term It's all about long term Because like planning
some of these things Might take a long time But the
long-term effects is, like, so beneficial.
Because sometimes my projects take a long time to plan.
But I know the moment I would upload it, or the moment I do
it, I know people are going to like it.
Because I put...
It's like, it's like, you know, when AAA companies rush a
game for Christmas, and you can tell it's rushed.
You can tell it's, like, super rushed, and, like, oh, like,
oh, you didn't put their real heart and soul into it.
that took like years to develop and like they clearly put a
lot of investment into it and stuff like that like that's
like the best comparison i can make regarding this like
don't be afraid to invest long term versus short term
because um if you believe in something enough then like and
like you know logically that this when you announce it or
like when you actually put
that this is what viewers want so like don't be afraid to
reinvest for long term type deal um and that's like really
how i felt like helped me a lot to grow the way i did before
i came back as an indie um and uh no being creative i know
where i'm i'm producer my role is majority as a producer i
have lots of ideas and i help and i provide these ideas for
people to make it into reality.
There are some people who are gifted in actually creating it
themselves.
Know where your strong suits are.
I know I don't have a lot of skills creating stuff in
general, but I know that I have lots of ideas that I know
how to make it reality.
Know what I want to make it in reality.
And I can organize stuff really well.
I can plan things and organize and bring people together.
Obviously, are when you're really creative creative streams
you can make creative streams as a niche there's a lot of
very creative streamers and there's a lot like there's like
one stream one twitter account that i follow i can't bring
up the name on the top of my head right now but they also
they always like retweet a lot of like very very creative
streamers that do their make their own like content they
make their create their own things like create their own um
what is it called create their own
like their own way of streaming their own toggles is
actually crazy there's like people I want to hire um and try
to like work with from those uh from those like the people
that do all these things because it's so creative like these
are like coders people that can code and stuff to code
better interactions like they're very creative people and uh
I would love to work with some of them in the future because
that's why I've been like following them along because like
it helps me with ideas and like stuff i have me potentially
do in the future uh so yeah anyway guys um that is all i
want to say as always everybody stay hydrated posture check
get up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you
stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody bye guys bye